OUR JOINT SUNSET REVIEW HEARING --
THIS IS JUST A TO THE MARCH
FIFTH AND WILL FIRST --
BEGIN OFF WITH --
INTRODUCTORY MARK SINCE THIS IS
A A JOINT HEARING ON A TURNOVER
TO CHAIR GLACIER.
THANK YOU AT CHAIR LOW --
THIS OF COURSE IS OUR CONTINUING
WORK FROM LAST WEEK WE LOVE
THESE --
SUNSET --
HEARINGS AND I LOOK FOR TO THE
IMPORT DISCUSSIONS TODAY --
TYPICALLY OF ABOUT THESE
REGULATORY PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
AS YOU EVER EVERYONE KNOWS WHO
FOLLOWS OUR WORK WE STRIVE TO
FIND THAT RIGHT BALANCE.
BETWEEN THE THE PROJECT IN THE
THE PUBLIC.
AND THE CONSUMERS WITH THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS THAT THESE
PROFESSIONS BRING TO US --
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSIONS TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS CHAIR
WELL FIRST BEGIN THEN WITH THE
ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS REVIEW
OF THE TEN SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
TO GET KINDLY CALL UP THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL BOARD.
THAT'S A PLEASE COME UP.
IN IT AS LISTED IN THE GENDER OF
THEIR ITEMS SIX THAT HAVE BEEN
LISTED.
AT TO BE DISCUSSED --
BY THE DENTAL BOARD --
AND AGAIN --
AND TOTALITY PLEASE FEEL FREE 2%
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY UP TO A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MINUTES.
AND OR SHORTER IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. TO GET UP TO FIFTEEN MINUTES --
PLEASE FEEL FREE PERCENT WHEN
YOU'RE READY AND THEN FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AFTER THIS
PRESENTATION WOMAN OPTION FOR
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO ALSO
PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING OUR NOBLE
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS FRAN BURTON.
IT IS MY GREAT PLEASURE TO SERVE
AS PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD.
JOINING ME TODAY ARE STEVEN
MORAL VICE PRESIDENT.
KAREN FISHER EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
SHARE WALLACE ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
AND CARLOS ALVAREZ.
AB ENFORCEMENT CHIEF.
I WILL BEGIN WITH A BRIEF
PRESENTATION.
AND AN OVERVIEW OF THE BOARD AND
THEN WE WILL --
ADDRESS THE ISSUES I PATH.
THE GENERAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
WAS CREATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE TO REGULATE DENTISTS. ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR YEARS
LATER.
THE BOARD REMAINS IN EXISTENCE
AND REGULATES THE PRACTICE OF
APPROXIMATELY NINETY THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED LICENSED DENTAL
PROFESSIONALS.
INCLUDING FORTY THREE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED NINE DENTISTS.
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANTS RDAS.
AND ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE REGISTERED
DENTAL ASSISTANT IN EXTENDED
FUNCTIONS.
IN ADDITION THE BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SETTING THE
DUTIES.
AND FUNCTIONS OF APPROXIMATELY.
FIFTY THOUSAND ON LICENSE DENTAL
ASSISTANTS.
OUR BOARD IS COMPRISED OF
FIFTEEN MEMBERS.
A PRACTICING DENTIST. ONE
REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST. ONE
DENTAL ASSISTANT.
BY PUBLIC MEMBERS WHO ACCOUNT
FOR ONE THIRD OF THE MEMBERSHIP.
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS THE
DENTISTS.
THE R. A. D. H. D. RDA AND THREE
PUBLIC MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY.
THE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE EACH
AT A POINT ONE PERSON.
I AM THE PUBLIC MEMBER.
APPOINTED BY THE SENATE.
OF THE EIGHT PRACTICING DENTIST
ONE MUST BE A MEMBER.
OF A FACULTY OF ANY CALIFORNIA
DENTAL SCHOOL.
VICE PRESIDENT MORAL CURRENTLY
FAILS THAT POSITION.
ADDITIONALLY ONE MEMBER IS
REQUIRED TO BE A DENTIST
PRACTICING IN A NON PROFIT
COMMUNITY CLINIC.
THERE IS CURRENTLY ONE PUBLIC --
VACANCY.
THE MISSION OF THE BOARD IS TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND PROMOTE THE ORAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
BY ENSURING QUALITY DENTAL
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ORDER TO FULFILL ITS MISSION.
THE BOARD IMPLEMENTS REGULATORY
PROGRAMS.
AND PERFORMS A VARIETY OF
FUNCTIONS SUCH AS SETTING
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS.
IN ISSUING AND RENEWING LICENSES.
INCLUDING A VARIETY OF PERMITS
AND CERTIFICATIONS.
THE BOARD ALSO HAS ITS OWN
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION.
WITH SWORN AND NON SWORN STAFF.
WHICH IS TASKED WITH
INVESTIGATING BOTH CRIMINAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE VIOLATIONS OF THE
DENTAL PRACTICE ACT.
AND OTHER LAWS.
AS PART OF THE DISCIPLINARY
FUNCTION AT THE BOARD.
IT ALSO MONITORS DENTISTS.
AND R. D. A.'S WHO MAY BE ON
PROBATION.
AND MANAGES A DIVERSION PROGRAM
FOR LICENSEES WHO PRACTICE
PRACTICE MAY BE.
IMPAIRED DUE TO ABUSE DANGEROUS
OUT.
THE GENERAL BOARD IS A SELF
SUPPORTING SPECIAL FINE.
THE TWO STAINS.
THAT OBTAINS ITS REVENUE FROM
LICENSING AND PERMIT.
VISA DENTISTS REGISTERED DENTAL.
AND REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANTS
AND EXTENDED FUNCTIONS.
WE RECEIVE NO MONEY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
THE REVENUES ARE DEPOSITED IN
MAINTAINED IN TWO SEPARATE
ACCOUNTS.
WHICH ARE NOT CO MINGLED THE
DENTISTRY FIND.
HAS AN APPROPRIATION OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND THE DENTAL ASSISTING FINE
AND APPROPRIATIONS OBJECTS UNDER
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION.
THE BOARD SUPPORTS A STAFF OF
SEVENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES WHO WORK
IN VARIOUS UNITS SUCH AS
ADMINISTRATION.
COMPLAINT IN COMPLIANCE
DISCIPLINE COORDINATION
INVESTIGATION AND ANALYSIS.
ENFORCEMENT EXAMINATION AND
LICENSING.
WE MAINTAIN TWO OFFICES ONE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND ONE AND THEN
OF COURSE WHEN OFFICE.
IN ORANGE COUNTY.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS.
AND IF THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS.
WE WILL BEGIN ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES THAT ARE OUTLINED IN
TODAY'S AGENDA [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR MORE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SERRA
WALLACE.
THE BOARD HAS BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK TO WHETHER IT IS RECEIVED
ANY COMPLAINTS RELATING TO
REGISTER DENTAL ASSISTANCE.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS RDAS THAT
HAVE NOT PASSED THE SUSPENDED
PRACTICAL EXAMINATION WHETHER IT
BELIEVES A PRACTICAL EXAMINATION
AS ESSENTIAL TO MEASURING
COMPETENCY OF RDAS.
AND WHETHER IT BELIEVES THE
PRACTICAL EXAMINATION SHOULD BE
REVIVED EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY OR IF ITS
CURRENT SUSPENSION SHOULD BE
MADE PERMANENT.
DURING THE BOARDS LAST SUNSET
REVIEW IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
CONCERNS WERE RAISED RELATING TO
THE PASSING RATE OF THE BOARD
RDA PRACTICAL EXAMINATION.
DISCUSSION SURROUNDING THESE
CONCERNS RESULTED IN THE PASSAGE
OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE SEVENTY NINE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONEY M. THAT
AUTHORIZED THE BOARD TO SUSPEND
THE PRACTICAL EXAMINATION.
IF FOR A VIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CAN THE PROFESSIONAL
EXAMINATION SERVICES.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS P. E. S.
CONCLUDED THE PRACTICAL
EXAMINATION WAS UNNECESSARY OR
DID NOT ACCURATELY MEASURE THE
COMPETENCY OF RDAS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BOARD ALONG WITH THE DENTAL
ASSISTING COUNSEL DETERMINED
THAT AN OCCUPATIONAL ANALYSIS OF
THE RT PROFESSION MUST BE
CONDUCTED TO DEVELOP A
DESCRIPTION OF CURRENT PRACTICE
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL JOB TASKS
THAT ENTRY LEVEL LICENSEES.
MUST BE ABLE TO PERFORM SAFELY
AND COMPETENTLY.
O. P. S. CONDUCTED THE
OCCUPATIONAL ANALYSIS IS
REQUESTED AND THE RESULTS OF THE
PROJECT WERE ALSO USED TO ENSURE
THE CONTENT OF WRITTEN PRACTICAL
AND LAWN ETHICS LICENSING
EXAMINATIONS.
REFLECTED THE KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS THAT ARE CRITICAL FOR
PUBLIC PROTECTION.
IN ADDITION TO THE OCCUPATIONAL
ANALYSIS OPS CONDUCTED A REVIEW
OF THE RDA PRACTICAL EXAMINATION.
AND RECOMMENDED THE BOARD
IMMEDIATELY SUSPEND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF IT.
FURTHER OPS CONCLUDED THERE WAS
A RELATIVELY LOW RISK OF HARM TO
THE PUBLIC FROM THE SUSPENSION
OF THE EXAMINATION.
BECAUSE OF OTHER MEASURES IN
PLACE SUCH AS THE REQUIREMENT
FOR APPLICANTS TO PASS A WRITTEN
EXAMINATION AND THE FACT THAT
RDAS.
ARE REQUIRED TO BE UNDER THE
GENERAL OR DIRECT SUPERVISION OF
A LICENSED DENTIST.
ON APRIL SIXTH TWO STOP.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE BOARD
VOTED TO SUSPEND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PRACTICAL
EXAMINATION.
AT ITS AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN MEETING THE BOARD AND
THE DENTAL ASSISTING COUNSEL
CONSIDERED ALTERNATIVES
PRESENTED BY OPS RELATING TO
ASSESSING THE COMPETENCY OF RDA
CANDIDATES. TO BE TO PERFORM THE
CLINICAL PROCEDURES NECESSARY
FOR LICENSURE.
THE BOARD APPOINTED A
SUBCOMMITTEE TO EVALUATE --
THAN A PRACTICAL EXAMINATION TO
BRING BACK TO THE BOARD AND THE
DENTAL ASSISTING COUNCIL FOR
CONSIDERATION AT A FUTURE
MEETING.
AFTER CONSIDERING FEEDBACK
RECEIVED DURING A STAKEHOLDER
WORKSHOP THE SUBCOMMITTEE
RECOMMENDED ALTERNATIVES AT THE
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
BOARD MEETING.
CONSIDERATION WAS GIVEN NOT ONLY
TO PUBLIC PROTECTION BUT TO
WHETHER THE NEW ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS WOULD ELIMINATE
OVERLY RESTRICTIVE ELIGIBILITY
STANDARDS.
OR STANDARDS OF PRACTICE THAT
UNDULY LIMIT COMPETITION BETWEEN
PROFESSIONALS OR PLACE UNDUE
BURDENS ON THOSE WHO WANT TO
ENTER THE PROFESSION.
ULTIMATELY THE BOARD AND THE
DENTAL ASSISTING COUNCIL VOTED
TO ADOPT AN ALTERNATIVE. TO THE
PRACTICAL EXAM WHICH REQUIRES
ELIGIBILITY FOR RT LICENSURE BE
BASED ON COMPLETION OF THE
CURRENT APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS.
AS ESTABLISHED BY CURRENT LAW
AND REGULATION.
AND SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION AND
PASSING OF THE ALREADY A WRITTEN
EXAMINATION AND THE RDA LAW AND
ETHICS WRITTEN EXAMINATION.
THE BOARD IN THE DENTAL
ASSISTING COUNSEL BELIEVE THAT
THIS OPTION WAS THE MOST
REASONABLE AN OPTIMAL IT WILL
NOT INTRODUCE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS TO RT LICENSURE.
THE DECISION IS SUPPORTED BY THE
FACT THE CANDIDATES ARE REQUIRED
TO TAKE AND PASS A WRITTEN
EXAMINATION.
AND ONCE LICENSED THE DUTIES ARE
SUPERVISED BY THE DENTIST
THEREFORE THE PUBLIC IS THAT
LITTLE RISK OF HARM.
I PRACTICAL EXAMINATION WOULD
NOT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
PROTECTION WE ARE NOT CONFERRED
BY SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM FOR WRITTEN
EXAMINATION.
SINCE THE SUSPENSION OF THE
PRACTICAL EXAMINATION IN APRIL
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE BOARD
IS ISSUED APPROXIMATELY FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED LICENSES
TO RDAS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
BOARD HAS NOT RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS RELATING TO RDAS
LICENSE WITHOUT HAVING TAKEN A
PRACTICAL EXAM.
THE BOARD DOES NOT BELIEVE A
PRACTICAL EXAMINATION IS
ESSENTIAL TO MEASURING
COMPETENCY OF RDAS TO BECOME
INITIALLY LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE PROFICIENCY IN
PERFORMING THEIR LICENSURE AND
IS RELATED TO THE RDA GAINING
FURTHER PRACTICE AND EXPERIENCE
IN DENTAL OFFICES UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF THEIR EMPLOYER
DENTISTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE SUPERVISING
DENTIST IS THE ULTIMATE JUDGE AN
ARBITER OF THE X..
OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE RTA
DEMONSTRATE SUFFICIENT
PROFICIENCY TO PERFORM THE RTA
DUTIES IN THE DENTIST'S OFFICE.
CURRENTLY THE SUSPENSION OF THE
PRACTICAL EXAMINATION IS ONLY
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THE BOARD RECOMMENDS THE CURRENT
SUSPENSION OF THE RDA PRACTICAL
EXAMINATION BE MADE PERMANENT.
AND THAT THE ELIGIBILITY FOR RT
LICENSURE BE BASED ON THE
COMPLETION CURRENT APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS.
I WISH I CURRENT LAW AND
REGULATION AND SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF PASSING OF THE
ALREADY WRITTEN EXAMINATION AND
RDA WANT AFFECTS WRITTEN
EXAMINATION.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KAREN
FISHER AND I'M GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING ISSUE NUMBER SIX
RELATING TO THE PORTFOLIO
EXAMINATION.
THE BOARD HAS BEEN ASKED TO
CHARACTERIZE THE SUCCESS OF
LICENSURE BY PORTFOLIO
EXAMINATION.
AND TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
REGARDING ANY ISSUES RELATING TO
HOW THIS PATHWAY TO DENTAL
PROFESSION IMPACTS STUDENTS.
SEEKING TO PRACTICE DENTISTRY
WITHIN AND OUTSIDE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE PORTFOLIO PATHWAY TO
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
INNOVATIVE METHODS OF DENTAL
LICENSURE.
THE CONCEPT OF THE BOARDS
PORTFOLIO CURRICULUM INTEGRATED
CLINICAL EXAMINATION WAS BORN
FROM THE IDEA THAT NO MORE HUMAN
SUBJECTS WOULD BE USED FOR POST
GRADUATION CLINICAL LICENSURE
EXAMINATIONS.
UPON THIS PREMISE THE BOARD MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A CURRICULUM
INTEGRATED CLINICAL LICENSURE
EXAMINATION. FOR STUDENTS
GRADUATING FROM DENTAL SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PORTFOLIO PATHWAY TO
LICENSURE ALLOWS STUDENTS TO
BUILD A PORTFOLIO OF COMPLETED
CLINICAL EXPERIENCES AND
CLINICAL COMPETENCY EXAMINATIONS.
IN SIX SUBJECT AREAS OVER THE
COURSE CODE COURSE OF THEIR
CLINICAL TRAINING IN DENTAL
SCHOOL.
INSTEAD OF TAKING A SET SINGLE
EXAMINATION ON A LIFE PATIENT.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE WEEKEND.
THE PORTFOLIO PROCESS OFFERS
MULTIPLE BENEFITS TO STUDENTS
AND PATIENCE INCLUDING LETTING
STUDENTS EXTEND TREATMENT OVER
MULTIPLE PATIENT VISITS WHICH
REDUCES THE STRESS OF A ONE TIME
TESTING EVENT.
AND MORE CLOSELY SIMULATES REAL
WORLD PATIENT CARE.
THE PATHWAY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PATIENTS TO
RECEIVE FOLLOW UP TREATMENT IS
NEEDED AND PROVIDES A METHOD BY
WHICH STUDENTS ARE READY FOR
LICENSURE UPON GRADUATION.
THIS PATHWAY TO LICENSURE HAS
THE FULL SUPPORT OF THE SIX
DENTAL SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER OF STUDENT PARTICIPATION
HAS DROPPED.
SOME HAVE SPECULATED THAT
STUDENTS ARE CONCERNED WITH
PORTABILITY BETWEEN STATES FOR
EXAMPLE I A STUDENT IS LICENSED
BY THE PORTFOLIO PATHWAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WITH THIS LICENSE BE ACCEPTED IN
ANOTHER STATE.
THE BOARD CONTINUES TO WORK WITH
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS TO RESPOND
TO CHALLENGES PRESENTED BY THIS
PATHWAY TO LICENSURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE PAST FOUR YEARS THE
BOARD HAS RESPONDED TO INQUIRIES
FROM OTHER STATES EXPRESSING AN
INTEREST IN THE CALIFORNIA
PORTFOLIO MODEL.
THE BOARD HAS MADE ALL MATERIAL
DEVELOPED FROM INCEPTION TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PORTFOLIO
PATHWAY TO LICENSURE.
AVAILABLE ON THE BOARD'S WEBSITE
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
INITIAL LEGISLATION.
THE CONSULTANT PSYCHOMETRIC EXAM
AND IT'S THE REGULATIONS AS WELL
AS THE CANDIDATE AN EXAMINER
HANDBOOKS. FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
OTHER STATES HAVE NOW HAVE THE
ROADMAP TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENT CALIFORNIA'S
CURRICULUM INTEGRATED CLINICAL
EXAMINATION SHOULD THEY CHOOSE
TO DO SO.
A NATIONAL MOVEMENT HAS BEGUN.
TO CONSIDER USING CALIFORNIA'S
HYBRID PORTFOLIO EXAMINATION AS
THE CLINICAL EXAMINATION
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
EFFORTS ARE BEING MADE BY THE
AMERICAN DENTAL ASSOCIATION THE
AMERICAN DENTAL EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE AMERICAN
STUDENT DENTAL ASSOCIATION. TO
PROMOTE A COMPENDIUM OF CLINICAL
COMPETENCIES BASED ON
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM THIS IS A
MEASURE I JUST WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT TO THE FIVE MINUTES
REMAINING FOR THE FULL
PRESENTATION OF AFFORD ITSELF SO
IF YOU WISH TO RENT AND THIS
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS.
PERFECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST AS
A REMINDER THAT THE BOARD WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE.
A WRITTEN RESPONSES TO ANY
MEMBERS OF THIS JOINT COMMITTEE
SHOULD THERE BE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS SO I CAN WRITTEN
RESPONSES CAN BE PROVIDED.
IN ADDITION TO THE TEST MONEY
MADE HERE TODAY SO --
ANY REMAINING A PRESENTATIONS
REMAIN COMMENTS OR ANY ITEMS
THAT WISHING TO BE ADDRESSED.
YEAH.
MORNING MY NAME IS DOCTOR
STEPHEN MARLEY.
DURING PRIOR SUNSET REVIEW THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE DISCUSSED
FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOL APPROVALS
AND ONE OF THE CURRENT PROCESS
FOR APPROVING FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOL TO SUFFICIENT.
OR WHETHER THE BOARD SHOULD
CONSIDER HIM ACCREDITING
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
COMMISSION ON DENTAL
ACCREDITATION COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS CODA. FOR FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOL APPROVALS THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT GRADUATES OF FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOL TO HAVE RECEIVED AN
EDUCATION.
THAT IS EQUIVALENT TO THAT OF
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THAT ADEQUATE
REPAIRS THEIR STUDENTS. FOR THE
PRACTICE OF DENTISTRY SHALL BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A GRADUATE OF APPROVED AT ALL
SCHOOLS.
THE BOARD'S AUTHORITY TO APPROVE
FOR IN DENTAL SCHOOL TO SOUNDED
IN BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
SECTION SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX POINT.
FOR THE INSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS
UPON WHICH THE BOARD EVALUATES
FORMED ALL SCHOOLS WERE
INITIALLY ESTABLISHED BASED UPON
THE COMMISSION ON DENTAL
ACCREDITATION.
STANDARDS USED FOR DENTAL
EDUCATION AT THAT TIME.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT AT THE TIME THAT THIS THAT
YOU WENT INTO EFFECT COATED DID
NOT HAVE A PROGRAM TO EVALUATE
INTERNATIONAL SCHOOLS?
WELL THROUGHOUT THE YEARS CODA
HAS CONTINUED TO REVIEW AND
REVISE ITS STANDARDS.
THE BOARD HAS NOT KEPT PACE WITH
THESE CHANGES BY UPDATING
REGULATIONS.
THE BOARD ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STANDARD SHOULD BE
UPDATED AND REFLECT CODA
STANDARDS HOWEVER.
COMPLETING THIS UPDATE THROUGH
THE REGULATORY PROCESS HAS
PROVEN VERY ARDUOUS.
THE PROCESS BY WHICH REGULATIONS
ARE UPDATED TAKES ANYWHERE FROM
NINE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
BECOME EFFECTIVE.
CODE IMPLEMENTS REVISIONS ON A
REGULAR BASIS AS AN EXAMPLE
BETWEEN JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND JANUARY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CODY
IMPLEMENTED REVISIONS TO THREE
EVENTS ACCREDITATION STANDARDS.
IF THE BOARD BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF BRINGING ITS EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS IN LINE WITH COTA.
IT IS LIKELY THAT BY THE TIME
THE PROCESS IS FINISH THOSE
STANDARDS.
AGAIN WILL HAVE BEEN REVISED BY
KOTA REALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE
BOARD TO KEEP CURRENT WITH CODE
IS STANDARDS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE ARE OVER OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS --
THERE HAVE BEEN ONLY THREE DAHLE
SCHOOL FOR IN THOSE SCHOOLS OUT
OF APPLIED. FOR APPROVAL TO THE
BOARD TO HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
AND ONE DID NOT COMPLETE THE
PROCESS.
STATUTES IMPORTANT PART ALSO
STATE THE FOLLOWING THE
LEGISLATURE HEREBY URGES ALL
DENTAL SCHOOLS.
IN THE STATE TO PROVIDE IN THEIR
CURRICULUM A TWO YEAR COURSE OF
STUDY THAT MAY BE UTILIZED BY
GRADUATES OF FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOLS. TO ATTAIN THE
PREREQUISITES FOR LICENSURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SINCE INCEPTION OF THIS STATUTE
FIVE OF THE CURRENTLY SIX DENTAL
SCHOOLS IN CAL I HOPE CALIFORNIA
HAVE ESTABLISHED THAT
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAM.
ADVANCES HAVE BEEN MADE IT
COATED WITH REGARD TO
INTERNATIONAL DENTAL SCHOOL
ACCREDITATION.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THE AMERICAN DENTAL
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CODE IS
STANDARD COMMITTEE ON
INTERNATIONAL ACCREDITATION.
GO TO HAS NOW A RIGOROUS AND
COMPREHENSIVE INTERNATIONAL
ACCREDITATION PROGRAM FOR PRE
DOCTORAL DENTAL EDUCATION
CURRENTLY THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
INTERNATIONAL DAHLE SCHOOLS
UTILIZING THE CODA CUMULATIVE
SERVICES AND ARE IN VARIOUS
STAGES OF THE APPROVAL PROCESS
[inaudible]
OF THE BILL BOARD BELIEVES THAT
THE BEST WAY TO MEET THE
LEGISLATURE'S NEED. TO ENSURE
THAT GRADUATES OF FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOLS I RECEIVE AN EDUCATION
THAT IS EQUIVALENT. TO THAT OF
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES IS TO REQUIRE
FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOLS TO
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE.
THE CODA INTERNATIONAL CONSUL
ASIAN PROCESS THAT IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO ALL FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FINAL.
REMARKS BY THE BY THE BOARD AT
THIS TIME.
OKAY AS SEEN IN ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I SEE A NUMBER
OF COLLEAGUES AND FIRST UP WITH
START WITH SENATOR HILL FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR IN TO THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION IT WAS --
QUITE ENLIGHTENING AND I
APPRECIATE THE GREAT WORK THAT
THE THAT THE BOARD DOES.
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
RELEASED IN THE PREVIOUS SESSION
WE HAD QUITE A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS AND LEGISLATION ON
PEDIATRIC ANESTHESIA ANASTASIA
SDGS -- AND
AND THANKFULLY --
CHAIR GLAZERS BILL --
IS NOW A HAS THERE BEEN ANY
THOUGHT OF AND I'VE HEARD THIS
FROM SOME OTHERS OF HAVING A AND
OF A A STATUTORILY REQUIRED
POSITION OF AN ORAL SURGEON ON
THE BOARD.
IS THAT BEEN CONTEMPLATED AT ALL
OR DO YOU DO YOU SEE THE BENEFIT
OF THAT --
IN THE CONTEMPLATION AND
DISCUSSION.
WE'VE HAD THE ADVANTAGE AS WE
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS.
OF HAVING SOMEONE WHO FEEL THAT
POSITION AND WE ARE WILL WELL
WELL AWARE OF THE FACT THAT IF
WE DON'T.
WHEN WHEN HE TERMS OFF OF THE
BOARD?
IT'S IT'S GOING TO BE IT SEVERE
LOSS -- I
CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD.
BUT I THINK THAT WE ALL HAVE
SEEN THIS SAYS CITY OF HAVING
SOME DEDICATED PERSON FOR THAT
POSITION.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ARCHULETA FOLLOWED BY SOME
MEMBER OBERNOLTE YES THANK YOU
LADIES AND JOHN FOR COMING
BEFORE US.
AND MY QUESTION ALMOST THE SAME
AS SENATOR HILL IN A MINUTE.
A LITTLE HIGHER ON THIS QUESTION --
THE ORAL BOARD --
THAT YOU YOU CONDUCT EVERY
SINGLE YEAR I'M SURE TO GET
PEOPLE IN AND SO ON THE THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE ORAL SURGEON
IT IS SO VERY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY OF OR
AND HOPEFULLY THAT ONE DAY THAT
THERE WILL BE SOMEONE --
ON THE BOARD OF THE COMPLETE THE
THE A PRACTICING DENTIST BUT
ALSO THE EDUCATION STANDARDS IT
MUST ALSO BE MET BY THE
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT
ASSISTING THAT DR.
SO WE NEED TO SEE WHERE THAT
EDUCATION IS GOING TO MATCH.
THE THE PRACTICE OF FOR SURGERY.
AND WITH TRANSPLANTS AND THINGS
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE.
AND I WOULD IMAGINE THE NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS THAT WE'VE HEARD --
BECAUSE WHEN YOU YOU'RE WATCHING
A TV COMMERCIAL THAT SAID YOU
WALKED IN ON MONDAY AND BY
MONDAY AFTERNOON YOU WALK OUT
WITH A COMPLETE SET OF TEETH.
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
AN ORAL SURGEON THE THE
PRACTICING DENNIS WILL ALWAYS
TELL YOU IT'S A LONG PROCESS --
SO I'M WANTING HOW YOU'RE
DRESSED IN THAT ISSUE OF THAT
ADVERTISEMENT THAT IS IN SOME
CASES MISLEADING.
BECAUSE IF YOUR BODY DOESN'T
ADJUST THAT IS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
I'LL START TO TAKE A STAB AT
THIS ONE SO I'M MY NAME IS KAREN
FISHER AND THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
THE DOWN BOARD.
WHEN WE SEE QUESTIONABLE
PRACTICES GOING ON WE DO START
INVESTIGATIONS AND WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THERE HAVE BEEN ANY
VIOLATIONS OF THE DENTAL
PRACTICE ACT?
SO WE DO ACT PROACTIVELY IN THAT
RESPECT --
BUT WE ALSO OUR COMPLAINT DRIVEN
STEVE COMPLAINTS FROM CONSUMERS
ABOUT TREATMENT PROVIDED BY ANY
KIND OF A DENTIST WHETHER IT'S A
PROCESS HONEST OR AN
ORTHODONTIST OR AN ORAL SURGEON
WE DO INVESTIGATE THOSE
COMPLAINTS FULL FULLY.
AND UTILIZE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS TO ASSIST US IN THAT
EFFORT.
SO TEN FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WE
WOULDN'T BE ASKING THIS QUESTION
BUT WITH THE TECHNOLOGY AND AND
INTERNET.
TELEVISION ADVERTISING AND SO ON
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THERE
DOING THAT --
MY CONCERNED IT WOULD GET TO
KEEP A GOOD EYE ON THAT
ABSOLUTELY AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RDAS ARE ARE IN TUNE WITH
THAT TYPE OF PRACTICE AND AS WE
LEARN AND AND TO FIND NEW WAYS.
TO TREAT THE PATIENT THAT THE
RDAS ARE ALSO GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY EDUCATE THEMSELVES.
TO MATCH SHOULD MEET AND THE
PROCEDURES THAT ARE WILL WILL E
FOLLOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
I JUST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OLD ABILITY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR --
I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION AS MUCH
AS A COMMENT I THINK QUITE OFTEN
WHEN WE HAVE THESE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS.
THE TENDENCY IS TO FOCUS ON ALL
THE PROBLEM ISSUES AND WE COME
ACROSS THIS KIND OF CRITICAL AND
SO BECAUSE OF THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PAUSE AND GIVE YOU
COMPLIMENTS WHEN YOU DESERVE A
COMPLIMENT.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
OUR FIRST THING IT IS TO SEE HOW
WILLING TO INNOVATE YOU ARE
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN WE'RE IN
OUR REGULATORY ROLE SOMETIMES WE
JUST STICK TO ORTHODOXY AND
WE'RE NOT WILLING TO TAKE RISKS.
AND OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING WITH
THE ELIMINATION FOR THE DENTAL
ASSISTANTS I THINK IT'S REALLY
REFRESHING I CAN COUNT ON ONE
HAND.
THE NUMBER OF TIMES THAT WE'VE
HAD TO ABORT COME IN HERE AND
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT WE DECIDED
THERE'S NO PUBLIC BENEFIT.
IN HAVING MORE OVERSIGHT AND SO
WE WANT TO SCALE IT BACK WHEN
THE STATISTICS AND THE DATA BACK
US UP -- SO
THANKS FOR STICKING TO YOUR GUNS
ON THAT --
AND ALSO THE LICENSURE BY
PORTFOLIO I THINK IS A REALLY
GREAT THING TO SEE WHERE YOU'RE
WILLING TO SAY WE HAVEN'T WE
THINK THAT'S A BETTER WAY OF
DOING IT.
AND WE'RE GONNA BUILD A SYSTEM
THAT COULD BE THE MODEL FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD SO.
THANKS FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING THERE AND TO KEEP IT UP
[inaudible]
DOCTOR PAT.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND THE
DOWNWARD BEING HERE AND THE WORK
THAT YOU DO --
I DID WANT TO ASK ABOUT
CONTINUING EDUCATION I SHOULD
VERY FRAME IT BY ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY FOR THIS YEAR IS THAT
THIS YEAR THE ONLY HEALTH
PROFESSION BOARD THAT WE'RE
VIEWING TODAY --
IT'S THE GENERAL USER QUESTIONS
I ASK.
ALMOST ALL THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS BOARDS --
SO WHAT COMES TO CONTINUING
EDUCATION FIRST OF ALL I DO MAKE
NOTE AND I THINK YOU HAD A BIT
OF RESPONSE IN TERMS OF THE
ACTUALLY THE FREQUENCY IN WHICH
PEOPLE DON'T COMPLETE THEIR
CONTINUED EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS --
SO I NEED AT THAT EIGHTEEN PER
POINT 5% OF DDS --
LICENSEES AND 45% OF THE RDA
LICENSEES FIELD AUDITS AND SENSE
OF DIED SO --
CERTAINLY THAT'S VERY CONCERNING --
CAN YOU PERHAPS SPEAK TO HOW YOU
PLAN TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SEEMS
TO BE A RATHER HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF PEOPLE THAT COMPLAIN OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION.
UL ATTEMPT THIS ONE TOO SO --
IT THE AUDITS OF THE REGISTERED
DENTAL ASSISTANTS ARE RELATIVELY
NEW.
AND SO UNFORTUNATELY OUR
RESPONSES THAT IF THEY HAVE
ESSENTIALLY --
SIGN THE AFFIDAVIT UPON LICENSE
RENEWAL THAT THEY HAVE THEIR
UNITS ARE REQUIRED UNITS WE
ISSUE A CITATION SAYING IN
ESSENCE THAT THEY HAVE NOT.
EXPRESSED A TRUTHFUL ANSWER IN
THAT RESPECT.
SO WE'RE WE'RE BEGINNING THE
PROCESS OF MONITORING AND AND
THE STAFF IS ALSO LOOKING AT
TRANS TO FIND OUT WHERE THE
PROBLEMS LIE IF PEOPLE ARE
TAKING CONTINUING EDUCATION THAT
THEY DON'T REALIZE IS NOT BOARD
APPROVED --
THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TRY TO
DEVELOP --
ESSENTIALLY PERHAPS OF NOTICES
ARE ADVISORIES THAT SAY WE'RE
FINDING THIS TREND HAPPENING BUT
WE ARE CONDUCTING THE THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION WE'RE
FINDING THAT A LOT OF DOGS EAT
THESE CERTIFICATES USE.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO BE --
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE AS WE GO ALONG
BUT WE DO ISSUE CITATIONS FOR
THOSE WHO DO NOT COMPLY WELL
CERTAINLY IS A LICENSED HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES OF TRACKING YOUR
CD -- THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS IS THAT
AND AND NOW SINCE IT MAKES NOTE
THAT -- AND
IT'S MY CLEAR FIGHT THE THE THE
BOARD.
ACTUALLY REVIEWS AND APPROVES
SEE COURSES OR NOT I THOUGHT YOU
DIDN'T DO YOU DO YOU DO THAT
YOURSELF OR DO YOU DIFFER TO USE
AN ACCREDITATION AGENCY.
WHO BASICALLY --
DECIDES.
WHICH SEE IS VALID OR NOT --
FOR PURPOSES OF THE DENTAL BOARD
FOR THE PURPOSE OF GENERAL
CONTINUING EDUCATION THE BOARD
APPROVES PROVIDERS BUT NOT THE
INDIVIDUAL COURSES OKAY DO YOU
HAVE TO MANDATORY COURSES
CURRENTLY FOR THE BOARD ADD TO
OUR INFECTION CONTROL AND THE
DENTAL PRACTICE ACT COURSE.
THOSE PARTICULAR COURSE CONTENT
OUTLINES ARE REVIEWED AND
APPROVED INDIVIDUALLY BY THE
BOARD AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION IS IS THAT IS THERE
SOME ENTITY THAT REVIEWS --
STE C. E. FOR WHEN YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE PROGRAM THAT'S ACTUALLY
CONTINUE EDUCATION IT'S NOT
MARKETING SESSION TO SELL SOME
KIND OF PRODUCTS --
THAT THEY WANT THEM PROFESSIONAL.
TO THEN --
PASS ON TO THEIR PATIENTS.
SO IS THERE SOME SORT OF
CONFLICT OF INTEREST POLICY THE
THROUGH THE BOARD ITSELF OR
THROUGH SOME OTHER ENTITIES THAT --
YOU DEPEND ON TO SURE THAT
THAT'S THAT THE SEEDS
APPROPRIATE IF THE BOARDS MADE
AWARE OF IN THE SITUATION IT
ISSUE WITH THE PROVIDER THAT WE
DO THE ANIMAL CONTACT THE
PROVIDER AND DISCUSS THAT WITH
THEM AND RUN AN INVESTIGATION OF
SORTS -- THE
PROVIDERS ARE ALSO REQUIREDTO
PROVIDE A LIST OF THE COURSES
THAT THEY PROVIDED OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS AND I WAS ARE AUDITED
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
OKAY AND SO JUST TO CLARIFY SO
BASICALLY IS THE BOARD DIRECTLY
THAT HAS TO REVIEW WHETHER TO MY
TO CONFLICT OF INTEREST ISSUES.
AND GONNA TO ASK BECAUSE KNOWING
HOW MANY BUT PERCENT OF PEOPLE
YOU THOUGHT IT FOR YOU SEE EASE
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE PROVIDERS
THEN DO YOU --
I THOUGHT IT TOO SURE THAT THEIR
ARMED CONFLICT OF INTEREST PAN
FOR THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS I'D
SAY THAT IT'S VERY LOW --
BUT EVERY SINGLE PROVIDER IS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE COURSE
INFORMATION THAT THEY OKAY ARE
YOU DEPEND ON OUR PLANES ARE YOU
PRACTICALLY AUDITING TO BE SURE
A SAMPLE TO BE SURE THAT THIS IS
NOT A PROBLEM IN THE SEA.
AND THE PROFESSION IT'S A
COMBINATION OF BOTH.
OKAY SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT PERCENTAGE THAT YOU
ACTUALLY PRO ACTIVELY AUDIT --
I THINK THAT I WELL I DON'T
THINK THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM IN THE DENTAL WORLD
HAVING SOME FAMILIARITY WITH IT --
A A A NOTE THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER.
SPORTS HAVE COME BEFORE US --
DOES DOES SEEM TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM WHERE
THERE'S AN ADEQUATE REVIEW IF
THE CONTINUING EDUCATION AND TO
ENSURE THE MAIN AND SOME BOARDS
ACTUALLY DO HAVE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICY WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDING SEE [inaudible]
YES NOW.
WE DO NOT HAVE A CAR OKAY I I
WOULD URGE THAT THE BOARD
CONSIDER THAT --
I THINK IT --
WE NEED TO BE SURE TO THE C. E.
THAT WERE REQUIRING MORE
MANDATING ON HER VARIOUS
PROFESSIONALS ACTUALLY IS ABOUT
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND THAT'S
NOT.
THAT -- THE
COURSES THAT THEY TAKE ARE NOT
ONES THAT ARE ACTUALLY MORE
DESIGNED --
TO MARKET --
FOR THE INTEREST OF THE PERSON
WHO'S PRODUCT AND SO FORTH --
SO THIS IS SOMETHING.
SO I THINK --
FOR EXAMPLE THE TRADITION
COUNCIL ON CONTINUING MEDICAL
EDUCATION --
THAT THE CREDITS --
LICENSING L. A C. --
FOR CME FOR AND IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION HAS CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICIES I THINK SOME
BOARDS DO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT.
OF WORDS WHEN IT COMES TO
CONTINUE EDUCATION TO HAVE
CONFLICT INTEREST POLICIES TO
ENSURE THAT THE REQUIRED
EDUCATION IS NOT IS ACTUALLY IN
THE INTERESTS OF THE PATIENTS.
AND AND PATIENTS TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF AND NOT IN INTEREST OF
THE PERSON WHO'S TEACHING COURSE
FOR THEIR FINANCIAL BENEFITS.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN MAY WE
CONTACT YOU TO DISCUSS THIS
FURTHER BECAUSE THERE REALLY HAS
NOT BEEN HONORED READER WE DO
ACCEPT --
CONTINUING EDUCATION FROM
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS PACE AND
SO WILL LOOK AND TO SEE WHETHER
THEY HAVE CONFLICT OF INTEREST
POLICIES THEMSELVES TO BECAUSE
WE DO ACCEPT THEM.
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST WE REALLY
HAD THIS IF YOU'RE OPEN TO
SHARING YOUR INFORMATION WITH WE
WE APPRECIATE THEM OF COURSE AND
I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
AS BY THE WAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IT --
AND THIS COMES THIS IS ALONG THE
LINES OF CONSUMER PRODUCTS WHERE
IT APPEARS LIKE --
FOLKS THAT ARE PROMOTING OR
SPEAKERS THAT ARE PROMOTING
COSMETIC PROCEDURES SUCH AS
BOTOX OR OR DHARMA FILLERS.
ARE ALLOWED TO COME IN BUT OF
COURSE DENTIST ON ALLOWED TO DO
THE PROCEDURE --
IF I IF I UNDERSTAND THAT
CORRECTLY IT APPEARS LIKE
THERE'S A BIT OF A DOUBLE
STANDARD --
HOW DOES THE BOARD APPROACH THAT
AND -- BUT I
WOULD IMAGINE THERE PROBABLY ARE
SOME DENNIS THAT ARE DOING THAT
WHAT'S THE ENFORCEMENT.
ON THAT OKAY --
SO THERE ARE DENTISTS THAT IF
THEY HAVE AN ELECTED FACIAL
COSMETIC SURGERY PERMIT ARE
ALLOWED TO PERFORM PROCEDURES
RELATING TO CUTS MEDIC USE OF
BOTOX.
BOTOX IS --
ALLOWED ESSENTIALLY IN THE USE
OF GENERAL DENTISTRY.
AS LONG AS THE DENTIST DOCUMENTS
IN THE DONALD.
RECORD ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE USE
IS STRICTLY FOR A DENTAL
PROCEDURE --
WITH REGARD TO PEOPLE COMING TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TEACHING
THE COURSE.
THE COURSES ARE OPEN.
TO ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO PAY THE
FEE AND TAKE THE CLASS.
MANY OF THEM ARE ATTENDED BY
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO.
IN THEIR OWN RIGHT CAN PERFORM --
CAN USE BOTOX FOR COSMETIC
PURPOSES ALSO --
ANY ORAL SURGEONS THAT ARE
LICENSED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND HAVE A MAN MEDICAL BOARD
LICENSE.
ARE ABLE TO USE BOTOX IN THE IN
THE WAY THAT IN THE SAME WAY
THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE CONSIDERED
A PHYSICIAN --
AND SURGEON.
DOES THAT ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION
ALSO WITH THE PROPER STERN GROVE
PROPER PERMIT A CERTIFICATION
AND NEXUS TO DENTAL PROCEDURES
RIGHT THAT PUT THAT CAN BE --
THE PROCEDURES CAN BE DONE YES
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION AND THEN JUST ONE
OTHER QUESTION WHAT IS THE BOARD.
BEEN ABLE TO DO TO BE ABLE TO
DECREASE --
THE TIME OF INVESTIGATIONS --
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE THAT
ARE --
LAUNCHED AGAINST A DENTIST.
OKAY WELL WE ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY ALWAYS TO REVIEW OUR
PROCESS IS TO IS TO MAKE SURE
THERE IS SUFFICIENT AS WE CAN
MAKE THEM WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF IT OF HAVING AN INTERNAL
AUDIT THAT WE'RE DOING AMONG
OURSELVES TO BE TRACKING.
THE TIME FRAMES THAT IT TAKES
WE'VE BEEN ALSO WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IN DECREASING OUR TIME
LINES FROM THE TIME THAT OUR
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION.
GOES TO TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND WE SEE AN
IMPROVEMENT IN THAT AREA SO.
OUR NUMBERS HAVE COME DOWN SINCE
OUR LAST TEST SENSOR REVIEW NOT
AS QUICKLY AS WE ALL WOULD HOPE
BUT WE CERTAINLY ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY.
IN THAT EFFORT --
TO TRY TO RESPOND TO CONSUMERS
AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IF THERE'S MORE AS
FAR AS QUESTIONS CONCERNS ALL
REACH OUT.
THANK YOU SOMEONE THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A DIGITAL
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME FROM ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
GAZING NO QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME
IT WILL NOW OPEN THE PORTION OF
THE MEETING TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING.
TO SPEAK OR PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WITH ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WISH.
TO SPEAK ON ANY ITEMS HERE TODAY --
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO GO TO THE
PODIUM AND AGAIN IF YOU CAN GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
A GOOD MORNING BRAND OF HIM AND
SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL BOARDS ASSOCIATION.
REALLY APPRECIATE AS ALWAYS THIS
LEGISLATURE'S OVERSIGHT --
OF THE DENTAL BOARD WE HAVE A
REALLY GOOD AT LONG STANDING
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
BOARD WE'VE BEEN PLEASED TO WORK
WITH THEM ON I'M SO I'M GOING
ISSUES INCLUDING SOME C. E.
REGULATIONS I KNOW ARE BEING
PROCESSED AS WELL AS THINGS LIKE
PORTFOLIO WHICH WE ARE VERY
EXCITED --
IN SUPPORT OF OF AND HOPING THAT
WE CAN GET THAT SORT OF BACK ON
TRACK BECAUSE IT IS REALLY.
INNOVATIVE IN THE WAY WE WANT TO
SEE DONE A LICENSURE I'M GOING
FORWARD.
SO -- THINGS
ARE GOING REALLY WELL WOULD VERY
MUCH ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET OF THE DENTAL
BOARD THANK YOU.
THE GERMANS AND MEMBERS GARY
COOPER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ORAL SURGEON AND ORAL
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGE
CERTIFICATION --
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DENTAL MORE SPECIFICALLY OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS AS SENATOR
HILL AND CENTER ARCHULETA
COMMENTED ABOUT PEDIATRIC
ANESTHESIA.
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED WITH THE
PROFESSIONALISM THE WE'VE SEEN
WITH THE BOARD AND THEIR STAFF --
LAST YEAR WE HAD --
SB FIVE WILL WANT US INTO
GLAZERS BILLS SO I WOULD
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
RECONSTITUTE THE BOARD IN YOUR
DELIBERATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM SEEING NONE
ANY.
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS FROM THE
BOARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN I
KNOW THAT SO PART OF THE
DISCUSSION WILL BE SUCH THAT
THEY'LL BE A NUMBER OF FOLLOW
UPS IN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
A WORKING COLLABORATION WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFFS RESPECTIVELY IN
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
YES.
IN THE PORTFOLIO EXAMINATION AND
AND IF I COULD JUST SAY A COUPLE
WORDS ABOUT THAT.
OF CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST TO
INTRODUCE.
A NON.
SINGLE EVENT PATIENT RELATED
LICENSING EXAMINATION FOR
DENTISTRY IN THE UNITED STATES.
I WAS --
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO.
THAT HAS STARTED A MOVEMENT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN IN
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR A JOINT.
TASK FORCE COMPOSED OF MEMBERS
OF THE AMERICAN DENTAL
ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN DENTAL
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION AND
AMERICAN STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
ISSUED A TASK FORCE REPORT.
IN SUMMARY THAT TASK FORCE
REPORT RECOMMENDED NUMBER ONE
DOING AWAY WITH THAT THE SINGLE
ENCOUNTER.
PATIENT OF BASED EXAMINATION
POST GRADUATION.
IN ITS PLACE. TO IMPLEMENT A
CURRICULUM IN CALIFORNIA
PORTFOLIO AS AN EXAMPLE.
AS TO WHAT THAT IS WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN.
COUNTRYWIDE THE THIRD
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO INCREASE
THE PORTABILITY OF LICENSES
BETWEEN STATES.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAJOR CONCERNS
AT THIS POINT WITH THE PORTFOLIO
EXAMINATION IS.
THAT AT THE PRESENT TIME.
IN ADDITION TO CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE TEN STATES.
THAT EXCEPT TO THE RESULTS OF
THAT LICENSING EXAMINATION.
THE OTHERS DO NOT.
SO ONE OF THE MAJOR PROBLEMS AND
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE.
IN MODERNIZING THE LICENSE YOUR
INITIAL LICENSURE AS WELL AS
PORTABILITY IS TO GET STATE
BOARDS IN LINE WITH GETTING
OFFERS THEIR TRADITION.
OF THE PATIENT BASED CLINICAL
EXAMINATION WHICH IS BEEN THE
STANDARD FOR YEARS AND THE
MODERNIZE THAT PROCESS.
THAT EXAMINATION.
HAS NOT DEMONSTRATED VALIDITY OR
RELIABILITY TO ANY SUCCESSFUL
EXTENT.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF A NUMBER OF THAT PASSED ALONG --
TO CHAIR GLACIER FOR YOU ARE
VERY MUCH THE DENTAL BOARD.
RECALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
ARCHITECTS BOARD AND THE
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS TECHNICAL
COMMITTEE
.
AS AS THEY ARE COMING UP I'D
LIKE -- TO
REMIND THEM AND AND ALL THE
OTHER BOARDS THAT ARE STILL TO
COME THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED A
GREAT STAFF REPORT WE THANK OUR
STAFFS.
ON THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
SIDE FOR PREPARING THAT I THINK
WE'VE ALL DONE OUR HOMEWORK.
AND WE'VE REVIEWED IT ALSO I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU --
TO TRYING NOT TO REPEAT THE
INFORMATION THAT'S ALREADY --
IN THE STAFF REPORT --
WE INVITE YOU --
TO TO GIVE US YOUR YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO
KEEP IT TO FIFTEEN MINUTES OR
LESS.
AND I KEEP IN MIND THAT WE DO
HAVE.
A GREAT OVERVIEW OF THE BOARD
ITSELF THEIR SUMMARY COMMENTS
YOU WANT TO MAKE THEIR THAT'S
GREAT.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOUR RESPONSE TO THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED SO WELCOME
[inaudible]
THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MORNING A I AM
SYLVIA QUAN PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARE EXPLORED.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS MARK
TRUSCOTT CHAIRMAN OF THE
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS TECHNICAL
COMMITTEE.
WHICH WERE GOING TO SHORTEN TO
L. A. TO SEE IF YOU CAN REMEMBER
THAT.
LARA ZENEGRA WHO IS OUR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND I MIGHT
MENTION THIS IS HER VERY FIRST
SENSORY VICIOUS BRAND NEW TO US.
AND DOING AN EXCELLENT JOB
ALREADY ANTI TRICIA REGUS IS THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE L. ATC
EVERYBODY MEMBER THAT STANDS --
FOR SO LET ME DESCRIBE WHAT THE
BOARD DOES.
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE BOARD AND THEN MR
TRUSCOTT WILL DO THE SAME FOR LA
T. C..
THE BOARD CONSISTS OF FIVE
ARCHITECTS AND FIVE PUBLIC
MEMBERS.
WE WERE ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN OH ONE AND HAVE A RICH
TRADITION OF PREVENTATIVE
INNOVATIVE.
PROGRAMS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
WE LICENSE THE PROSELYTIZATION
THOUSAND ARCHITECTS IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE A BUDGET OUR PRICING FOR
MILLION.
AND A DEDICATED STAFF OF CLOSE
TO THIRTY PEOPLE.
WE ALSO HAVE TO ARCHITECT
CONSULTANTS.
IN OUR ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM WHO
INSURE THAT CASES IN VAULTING
PROFESSIONAL PRACTICE.
ISSUES ARE THOROUGHLY
INVESTIGATED. TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS AND ENSURE THEIR
BUILDINGS PERFORM APPROPRIATELY
IN OUR COMPLEX CHALLENGING.
PRACTICE CONTEXT ARE LICENSING
STANDARDS ARE ROBUST BUT
REASONABLE.
WE REQUIRE EIGHT YEARS OF
TRAINING AND EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE IN ARCHITECTURAL WORK.
WHICH INCLUDES THE STRUCTURE
TRAINING.
EXPERIENCE PROGRAM CONSISTING OF
NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND HOURS
ACROSS SIX PRACTICE AREAS.
CANDIDATES MUST ALSO PASS A SIX
DIVISIONAL A SIX DIVISION
NATIONAL EXAM.
FINALLY IN RECOGNITION OF
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE SEISMIC
ENERGY ACCESSIBILITY FAR
PREVENTION AND LEGAL STANDARDS.
WITH MINISTER CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPLEMENTAL WHICH WE CALL CST.
TO ASSESS A CANDIDATE'S ABILITY
TO SAFELY PRACTICE AND OUR
UNIQUE AND DYNAMIC CONTEXT. ONE
COMPONENT OF OUR STANDARDS IS
THAT WE ARE VERY PROUD OF IS OUR
MULTIPLE PATHWAYS INTO THE
PROFESSION.
A PROFESSIONAL DEGREE IN
ARCHITECTURE A RELATED DEGREE AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE OR FIVE YEARS
SIX EXPERIENCE CAN ALL MEET THE
BOARDS FIVE YEAR REQUIREMENT.
FOR EDUCATION OR EXPERIENCE OR A
COMBINATION THEREOF.
THE BOARD'S INVOKED THE ENFORCER
PROGRAM WORKS WHAT POTENTIALLY
WITH BUILDING DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT.
THE BOARDS BUILDING OFFICIAL
CONT --
CONTRACT PROGRAM IN ADDITION TO
CONSUMER EDUCATION.
THE BOARD WORKS CLOSELY WITH
PROFESSIONAL GROUPS TO ENSURE
THAT ARCHITECTS UNDERSTAND
CHANGES IN LAWS CODES AND
STANDARDS.
ALL THESE INITIATIVES UNDERSCORE
THE BORE THE BOARD'S FIRM BELIEF
THAT IT MUST BE BOTH.
STRATEGIC AN AGGRESSIVE.
EMPLOYING THE PREVENTIVE
MEASURES NECESSARY TO
EFFECTIVELY PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE.
SO I WANT TO JUST BRIEFLY TELL
YOU WHAT HAS CHANGED SINCE OUR
LAST REVIEW.
OUR NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
LAUNCHED A NEW PROGRAM IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE INTEGRATED PATH TO
LICENSE SIR I PANEL.
WHICH ALLOW STUDENTS TO COMBINE.
EDUCATION AND WORK IN A MORE
ACCELERATED MANNER WHILE EARNING
THEIR DEGREES.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS FIVE L.
I. PAL PROGRAMS --
FROM SAN DIEGO ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE BAY AREA.
WE REDUCE THE REQUIRED WAIT TIME
FOR CANDIDATES WHO TAKE.
ANY TO RETAKE THE CALIFORNIA
EXAM.
MOST SOME DO NOT PASSED THE
FIRST TIME --
IT JUST THE WAY IT IS THEY NEED
TO RETAKE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPLEMENTAL EXAM FROM HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS. TO NINETY DAYS AND
THAT'S WAS RESPONSE TO A LOT OF
REQUESTS FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
AND THEN WE RECENTLY BEGAN TO
ACCEPT ONLINE CREDIT CARD
PAYMENTS FOR LICENSE RENEWALS
FINALLY.
WE ARE IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND WE FINALLY DID IT.
SO WITH THAT I'M GOING TO
INTRODUCE MR TRUSCOTT TO PROVIDE
THE OVERVIEW FOR THE LA T. C..
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARK
TRUSCOTT AND I'M CHAIRMAN OF THE
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS TECHNICAL
COMMITTEE.
AND I'VE SERVED ON THE
COMMITTEES SINCE SEPTEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE LA T.
C. IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
EXAMINATION LICENSURE AND
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS CONCERNING
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS.
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS ARE THE
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS WHO SHAPE
THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT FOR
PRESERVATION AND HUMAN YEARS.
IN A MANNER WHICH PROTECTS THE
HEALTH SAFETY [inaudible]
AND WELFARE.
THE ONLY TO SEE IS A FIVE MEMBER
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF
THE BOARD.
CONSISTING OF LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS.
THE BOARD OF LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS I'M SORRY THE BOARD
OF LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS WAS
CREATED.
BY THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE AND THE LA
T. C. WAS LATER ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN TO REPLACE
THE BOARD OF LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS.
IN THE LAST REPORT THE LA T. C.
EXPANDED PATHWAYS TO LICENSURE
BY ALLOWING EDUCATION CREDIT FOR
AN ARCHITECTURE DEGREE.
PARTIAL COMPLETION OF A
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTURE DEGREE
AND PARTIAL COMPLETION OF A
EXTENT AN EXTENSION CERTIFICATE
AND LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTURE.
SINCE THEN THE LA TO SEE
CONTINUE TO REDUCE BARRIERS TO
LICENSURE.
AND APPROVED ALLOWING CREDIT FOR
RELATED DEGREES BOTTLE OR IT AND
ASSOCIATE.
NON RELATED DEGREES BOTTLER IT
AN ASSOCIATE.
AND AN EXPERIENCE ONLY PATHWAY.
WE LICENSE APPROXIMATELY. THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS HAVE A BUDGET OF ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS AND A
DEDICATED STAFF OF FIVE WE ALSO
HAVE EXTERNAL CONTRACTS WITH TO
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS CONSULTANTS
FOR OUR ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM TO
ASSIST WITH THE TECHNICAL REVIEW.
OF CASES INVOLVING A
PROFESSIONAL PRACTICE ISSUES.
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS OFFER IN A
SOCIAL ESSENTIAL ARRAY OF TALENT
AND EXPERTISE TO DEVELOP THE AND
IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS FOR THE BILL
TO NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
HAS WITH THE BOARD THE LA T. C.
HAS FOUND THAT ACTING PREVENTED
TO FLEE.
AND PROACTIVELY IS THE BEST USE
OF ITS RESOURCES. TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIGHT IT'S
REQUIRED TOTAL OF SIX YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
AND OR EDUCATION.
IN ADDITION CANDIDATES MUST PASS
A FOR SECTION NATIONAL EXAM
ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPLEMENTAL EXAMINATION. TO
ASSESS THE CANDIDATE'S ABILITY.
TO SAFELY PRACTICE IN OUR
DYNAMIC ENVIRONMENT.
WHAT'S CHANGED SINCE THE LAST
REVIEW.
IN ADDITION TO EXPANDING
PATHWAYS THE LA T. C. HAS
REVAMPED ITS WEBSITE INCLUDING
INCORPORATING THE DCA SEARCH
TOOL THAT ENABLES CONSUMERS TO
SEARCH FOR ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
IN REAL TIME AND IS IN THE
PROCESS OF LAUNCHING ONLINE
CREDIT.
RENEWAL PAYMENTS IN MAY WHICH
WERE VERY EXCITED ABOUT ALSO.
NOW MRS INDIGO WILL PRESENT
THEIR RESPONSES TO THE ISSUES
AND QUESTIONS FOR THE BOARD AND
LA T. C..
THANK YOU WERE AT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THOSE RESPONSES JUST
A NOTE THAT IF USED UP A LOT OF
YOUR TIME JUST IN THE OVERVIEW
SEE OF ABOUT SIX MINUTES TO GO
TO THE ISSUE SO PLEASE.
BE CONCISE THE MORNING GLORIES
IN A EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
BOARD ON THE FIRST ISSUE EVEN
ASKED ADDRESS IS NUMBER THREE ON
FINGERPRINTING.
THE COMMITTEE NOTES THAT
CURRENTLY OUR LICENSEES ARE ONLY
REQUIRED TO SELF DISCLOSE HOW
CAN THE BOARD BE CERTAIN THEY'RE
NOT MISSING ANY INFORMATION.
APPLICANTS ARE REQUIRED TO SIGN
THE APPLICATION --
PENALTY OF PERJURY --
BUT WE WE CERTAINLY CAN BE
CERTAIN THAT WE'RE NOT MISSING
ANY INFORMATION SO WE'D BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALL OF THAT --
COMMITTEES DIRECTION ON WHETHER
OR NOT YOU WOULD LIKE THE BOARD
TO BEGIN FINGERPRINT APPLICANTS --
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR IS INFORMAL
LICENSE CONFERENCES --
THE COMMITTEE PROPOSES TO ALLOW
AT THE EXACT OPPOSITE TO
DELEGATE THIS AUTHORITY
CURRENTLY THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
CAN HOLD AN INFORMAL CONFERENCE
WITH THAT LICENSEES RECEIVED A
CITATION WHICH HAPPENS
FREQUENTLY --
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE ABILITY FOR
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO BE ABLE
TO DELEGATE THIS TO THE MOST
LIKELY WOULD BE OUR SYSTEM
EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
AND IT WOULD JUST BE AM IN THE
INSTANCE WHEN THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER IS UNAVAILABLE OR IF
THERE'S A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
IF THE EXACT OFFICER NEW EITHER
THE PARTIES THAT WERE
PARTICIPATING IN THE CONFERENCE.
SO WE WOULD --
WE ARE THE BOARD HAS
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES --
AND ARE REGULATIONS THAT THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER MUST FOLLOW
AND HOLDING THE CONFERENCE AND
WHOEVER AT THE AUTHORITY IS
DELEGATED TO WHAT FOLLOW THOSE
SAME REQUIREMENTS --
THE THIRD ISSUE --
WE'VE BEEN ASKED ADDRESSES
NUMBER SIX THE WRITTEN CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS THE BOARD PROPOSING
TO MAKE A FEW MODIFICATIONS TO
OUR EXISTING WRITTEN CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS --
THE COMMITTEE ASKED HOW LONG
WITHOUT THEIR CONTRACTS --
FOR CHANGES SO --
WE DO THINK IT MIGHT BE
ADVISABLETO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS UNTIL JULY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TO GIVE.
ADEQUATE TIME TO NOTIFY
LICENSEES --
WE WOULD BEGIN EDUCATING THEM AS
SOON AS THEY REQUIREMENTS ARE
ADOPTED WE DO --
AT EMAIL LISTSERVS WERE
LICENSEES AND WE ALSO PARTNER
WITH OUR ASSOCIATION TO DO
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH TO ENSURE
THAT THEY WERE AWARE OF THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS.
I'M GOING TO MOVE INTO THE
ISSUES FOR THE LA T. C. --
THE FIRST ISSUE IS ALSO IS
SIMILAR IT'S ISSUE NUMBER TWO
FOR WRITTEN CONTRACTS --
THE LA TO SEE IS GOING TO USE --
UNDERTAKE AND LATER THIS YEAR
OCCUPATIONAL ANALYSIS FOR THERE
ARE CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENTAL EXAM
AS PART OF THAT THEY DO OUT
REACH ALL OF THEIR LICENSEES TO
SURVEY THEM SO WE WOULD INCLUDE.
NOTIFICATION THE REQUIREMENTS AS
PART OF THAT SURVEY BUT WOULD
ALSO AGAIN SUGGEST THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL JULY ONE FOR IT TO ALLOW
ADEQUATE TIME FOR OUTREACH.
AND THEN THE LAST QUESTION FOR
ELLIE T. C. IS ISSUE NUMBER
THREE THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
DUTIES --
THE BOARD AND I LIKE TO SEE YOU
TRY -- TO
HAVE SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS AND
PROCEDURES IN PLACE --
AND SO WE NOTED THAT THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER IS NOT ALLOWED
TO APPROVE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
FOR REVOCATION OR SURRENDER OF A
LICENSE. FOR THE LAT SEAT WHILE
THE DETECT OFFICER THAT HAPPEN
VERY OFTEN IN THE PAST THREE
YEARS THE LEDS TIAS HAD ONE
REVOCATION AND ONE SURRENDER --
BUT JUST KNOW THAT THIS WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY --
TO MAKE THE REQUIREMENTS SIMILAR
TO THE BOARDS AND WOULD ALLOW
THE PROCESS TO MOVE A LITTLE
LITTLE BIT MORE QUICKLY THERE'S
NOT A LONG DELAY --
BUT IT DOES HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
QUARTERLY BOARD MEETING FOR
ACTION CURRENTLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
LOOKING TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THEY MAY HAVE.
A CENTER ARCHULETA.
GOOD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MATTER
PRESIDENT IF I MAY.
SAY THANK YOU TO YOUR YOURSELF
WHEN YOU'RE BORED WITH SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT CONSUMERS
OBVIOUSLY HAVE IN TODAY'S WORLD
THE UNLICENSED PRACTICING.
OF PEOPLE WHO PROFESS TO BE
ARCHITECTS THAT'S AN ISSUE OUT
THERE THE AS THE ACTIVITY
INCREASED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS --
IN ALSO THE FACT THAT --
HOW DO WE HANDLE THOSE
COMPLAINTS AND --
RECTIFY AND WITH THAT WITH THAT
CONSUMER.
AND THEN I'M GOING TO ADD ONE
OTHER CRITICS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN --
TO ENCOURAGE EVERY CITY TO GO
OUT AND START LOOKING TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
CONSTRUCTION OF LARGE PROJECTS.
SHOULD ONE OF THE FIVE
ARCHITECTS BE AN EXPERT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF SUCH PROJECTS.
MAY I ASK FOR ANSWER THE SECOND
PART AND THEN I WILL ASK NATO.
TO ADDRESS THE FIRST PART --
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING --
I HAPPEN TO BE.
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OUR PROTECTIVE AMONGST OTHER
THINGS BUT YOU'RE RIGHT IT
HAPPENS [inaudible]
TO BE COINCIDENTAL.
AND NOW WITH THE EMPHASIS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I THINK IT
IT'S NOT A BAD IDEA AT ALL --
IT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD CHECK IN WITH THE
APPOINTMENTS OFFICE. TO SAY HERE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
ARCHITECTS THAT WE KNOW AROUND
THE STATE THAT HAVE THE SIX
EXPERTISE.
AND THEREFORE MAYBE THEY SHOULD
COME TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE STATE
IN ORDER --
TO PROMOTE.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
AND AND DEAL WITH THE CRISIS
BECAUSE I'M SURE EVERY CITY
MUNICIPALITIES OUT THERE IT'S
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE ARCHITECT
THAT HAVE THE EDUCATION THE FEEL
OF THE EXPERIENCE.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SO
THAT'S IMPORTANT AND IF YOU WILL
GO ON TO THE NEXT QUESTION ABOUT.
THE THE UNLICENSED AND I BELIEVE
THAT OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
THAT WE'VE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN LIGHT OF MY
SELECTIVITY BUT IT IS CERTAINLY
ONE OF THE MAIN --
COMPLAINTS THAT WE GET IT IS IN
REGARDS ON LICENSE ACTIVITY --
SO WE DO TRY TO DO OUTREACH TO
CONSUMERS SO THEY'RE AWARE OF
THE REQUIREMENTS AND THERE IS AN
EXEMPTION THE LAW.
FOR A SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING BUT
WE TRY TO EDUCATE CONSUMERS AS
TO WHEN AN ARCHITECT IS REQUIRED
BUT THEY SHOULD LOOK FOR IN
CHOOSING AN ARCHITECT --
AND SOMETHING WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON AND DO ADDITIONAL
OUTREACH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT --
GREAT --
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND WHAT
YOU DO FOR THE COMMUNITY AS FAR
AS ARCHITECTS AND LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS.
AN ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN PROBABLY
AND AT LEAST MY DISTRICT.
ARE EIGHTY A ISSUES.
AND ISSUES WHERE PLANS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED THE BUILDER --
HAS RECEIVED THE PERMIT THE
PLANTS BEEN APPROVED.
THE WORK HAS BEEN DONE ACCORDING
TO SPEC TO FIND OUT THAT.
A WHETHER IT BE MONTHS OR YEARS
LATER A LAWSUIT IS FILED BECAUSE
OF EIGHTY EIGHT VIOLATIONS.
AND I KNOW IT IS ADDRESSED --
IN THE MATERIAL HERE WHAT IS --
WHAT IS THE ANSWER WHAT CAN YOU
DO TO HELP --
AFFECTED LEE --
BRING AWARENESS TO THE
ARCHITECTS AS FAR AS ADA.
COMPLIANCE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PLANS ARE ACCURATE.
AND THE BUILDERS AND THOSE THAT
ARE BENEFITING FROM THAT PERMIT
AND IN THEIR PROJECT ARE NOT IN
VIOLATION.
AND DON'T GET SUED.
I WAS MARK TRUSCELLO AGAINST
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT DAY IN THE
PROFESSIONAL WORLD ENGINEERS
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS ARCHITECTS
ALL LOOK AT EIGHTY A ISSUES SO
WHAT IT'S ACTUALLY I I THINK
THAT -- IT'S
GETTING A LOT BETTER THAN I WAS
SAY THIRTY YEARS AGO IN TERMS OF
ACCESSIBILITY.
I WOULD STATE TO THE AND SILICON.
FOLLOW UP ON THIS BUT THE
ARCHITECTS THEMSELVES GO TO A
VERY RIGOROUS CAST --
TRAINING SCENARIO WHERE THEY
HAVE.
TO BE CERTIFIED RIGHT AND YOU
CAN PICK UP ON NOT THAT'S RIGHT
WELL FIRST OF ALL WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET A BUILDING PERMIT.
UNLESS ALL THE ADA ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE.
AND MARK MARK IS REFERRING TO IS
THE CAST CERTIFICATION WHICH IS
A VERY HIGH LEVEL SPECIALIZED --
CERTIFICATION FOR ARCHITECTS WHO
ARE --
EXPERTS REAL EXPERTS BUT I WOULD
I WOULD REALLY.
PUT MY STICK MY NECK OUT HERE
AND SAY THAT WE CAN'T GET A
PERMIT -- I
ACTUALLY HAD AN INCIDENT MIGHT
ONE PROJECT IN MIND WHERE WE
WERE OFF ONE INCH.
IN HEIGHT AND THE BUILDING
INSPECTOR ACTUALLY MANAGED TO
REDO THE FLOORING SO THAT IT
LINED ONE INCH.
SO -- I
THINK THAT WITH KALBA WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BUILDING OFFICIALS WE ARE VERY
COOPERATIVE IS SOMETIMES
CONTENTIOUS RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE
THEY DO WATCH EVERY INCH.
YEAH SO I'M NOT TOO WORRIED
ABOUT THAT --
IN IN THE SENSE OF OUR APPROVALS
PROCEDURES THAT HAPPENS.
I THINK PRETTY RIGOROUSLY.
OKAY AND I I APPRECIATE THAT.
I ALSO HAVE ONE THING TO THAT.
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS --
ARCHITECTS OF HAD CANOEING
EDUCATION IN ACCESS --
REQUIREMENTS AND EIGHTY EIGHT
AND SO WE WOULD CONTINUE TO SEE
I THINK IMPROVEMENTS WITH --
THE REQUIREMENTS SIMPLY FEEL
RIGHT I THINK THAT WAS THE
ANSWER I WAS LOOKING --
FOR NOT NO WORRIES BECAUSE OF A
BUILDER INSPECTORS INVOLVED THAT
MEANS A PERMIT WAS ISSUED.
AT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT --
SO AS FAR AS THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION BECAUSE THERE ARE LAWS
THAT CHANGE DIFFERENT THINGS
HAPPEN.
AND SO THERE IS PURSUE THEY HAVE --
TO EVERY TWO YEARS NEED TO
COMPLETE FIVE HOURS AND
DISABILITY ACCESS REQUIREMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ANSWERS WELL I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SELLING
THE GRAYSON --
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AT THE
FIRST OF ALL I AGREE WITH YOUR
DECISION NOT TO FINGERPRINT
EVERYONE APPLIES I'M NOT SURE
HOW THAT HELPS --
THE I DID DEVON BRIEF QUESTION --
REGARDING BREEZE --
EX I UNDERSTAND THAT --
IS THAT --
YOU'RE NOT ON BREEZE --
FOR LOTS OF GOOD REASONS AND BUT
YOU STILL HAVE TO PAY FOR IT --
SO -- MAYBE
YOU CAN TELL ME DID YOU EVER
HAVE TO HAVE TO RAISE FEES TO
COVER THIS THING --
THIS --
EXPENSE OR DID YOU BECAUSE YOU
SPEND MONEY HAD TO PROVIDE MONEY
FOR THIS --
PROGRAMS THAT --
SYSTEM THAT YOU.
DO NOT MEET YOUR NEEDS.
ARE WE HAVE NOT HAD TO RAISE
FEES TO MEET OUR OBLIGATIONS TO
PAPER BREEZE UP FOR EITHER
PROGRAM -- I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT WE HAD TO FORGO DOING I'VE
ONLY BEEN WITH THE BOARD SINCE
LAST YEAR AS INDICATED --
SO I'M NOT AWARE THAT THERE'S
ANY LARGE PROJECT THAT WE HAD TO
FORGO AT THIS POINT --
SO WE ARE AT ONE OF THE PHASE
THREE PROGRAM SO WE'RE CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING OUR BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PROCESS AND
COMPLETING OUR MAPPING TO
DETERMINE WHAT MIGHT COME
FORWARD.
SO WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS POINT
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COSTS
WILL BE FOR A NEW SYSTEM IF WE
WOULD NEED A FEE INCREASE OR ANY --
BCP NO I I APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER MY CONCERN ABOUT BREEZES
AND BOTH ON BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARS A MEMBER IAN T..
AS IS THAT.
IT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES BOB IS
VERY PROBLEMATIC AND
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THE COST
OF THIS PROBLEM.
IS BASICALLY JUST PASSED ON TO
LICENSEES.
NOT THE GENERAL FUND --
BASICALLY PEOPLE AND YEAH MAYBE
IT'S NOT SUCH A BIG DEAL BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN WHY.
WE'VE --
WASTED TAXPAYER MONEY EXCEPT I
WOULD SAY THAT PEOPLE PAY FEES
FOR LICENSES WHEN THEY'RE PAYING
FOR THINGS THAT DON'T WORK --
THAT'S A FORM OF A TWO YEAR TAX
AND I THINK WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN COLLEAGUES
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
PATH THE PUBLIC.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NINE A ANYONE
HERE FROM THE PUBLIC WHICH IS TO
SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS ON THIS
REVIEW PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE.
YOU MAY I INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
YOUR AFFILIATE WITH.
GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION OUR COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S JOHN NICHOLSON LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECT HERE IN SACRAMENTO I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS WE ARE THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THE THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
LICENSEES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR ON THE LA TC'S A
REPORT TO YOU TODAY AND AND OUR
SUPPORT FOR WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU TODAY --
WE BEING A TRADE ASSOCIATION OF
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS WE WE TAKE
OUR JOB SERIOUSLY AND IT AS IT
PERTAINS TO THE PROTECTION OF
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
OUR PUBLIC.
AS WELL AS DESIGNING --
SUSTAINABLE WORK AND PLAY AND SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING í
AGAIN -- FOR
LISTENING TO ALL THE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY I'M JUST FOLLOWING UP
ON SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES WORK AS
WELL MY NAME IS RICHER EISNER.
I'M A LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTURE --
JUST BRIEFLY ALL THE POINTS HAVE
BEEN MADE I REALLY DON'T NEED TO
REGURGITATE EVERYTHING THAT WAS
SAID YOU KNOW I NEED TO OKAY LET
ME TOO OKAY SO IT'S JUST
BASICALLY.
THAT CCS AWAY WHICH I'M
REPRESENTING.
IS ABOUT --
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND I'M INCOMPLETE WE'RE HERE WE
ARE IN COMPLETE SUPPORT.
OF CONTINUING THAT OKAY THAT'S
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE FOR **** THINK ANY
ANYBODY ELSE.
GOOD MORNING --
MELISSA BARTON REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS --
WERE IN ASSOCIATION OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS A MARKET OF
ARCHITECTURE PROFESSIONALS.
THE A I A CALIFORNIA SUPPORT --
EXTENDING THE SUNSET ON THE
CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD TRY
TO BE BRIEF --
WE BELIEVE IT FUNCTIONS WELL.
IT'S A MODEL BOARD AND WE
CELEBRATE CELEBRATE.
THAT -- A
CALIFORNIA WORKS VERY WELL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD --
IN ALL ASPECTS WHEN WE AGREE AND
WHEN WE DISAGREE --
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN IT'S
TO BARK TAX I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON
ITEMS FIVE AND SIX THE A A
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS RE
ESTABLISHING A MINIMUM CRITERIA
FOR CONTINUING EDUCATION.
AS MISS IN A GUY HAD MENTIONED
CURRENTLY ARCHITECTS ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE FIVE HOURS
OF ACCESSIBILITY.
EVERY TWO YEARS.
THE A I CALIFORNIA'S A PROVIDER
OF ACCESSIBILITY --
IT CONTINUING EDUCATION COURSES
TAUGHT BY EXPERTS --
THAT ARE QUALITY AND ON DEMAND
COURSES THE I A CALIFORNIA
BELIEVES THAT THERE IS VALUE.
IN ESTABLISHING MINIMUM CRITERIA
AS TEARS QUESTION CONTENT OFFER
TO LOW VALUE I'LL SWEAR.
THERE'S NO QUALITY OVERSIGHT
CURRENTLY AND WE SUPPORT --
THE CALVET ARCHITECT BURDEN
THOSE EFFORTS LAW NEED UPDATING.
WE SUPPORT CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS
BOARD IT'S IN THE INTEREST OF
THE A CALIFORNIA TO COMMUNICATE
WITH OUR MEMBERS --
IF THE REMAIN AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ENACTED.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING ANYBODY ANYBODY
ELSE I WANT TO WISH.
GOOD GOOD SPEED TO THE SUB BOARD.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE
PUBLIC PORTION --
AND I INVITE YOU IF YOU HAVE ANY
CONCLUDING COMMENTS TO WHAT TO
MAKE THEM THE WHITES WILL WRAP
THIS UP.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU TO THE BOARD
MEMBERS THANK YOU THE
PROFESSIONALS OR THIS IS YOUR
FIRST SUNSET REVIEW DID OKAY.
HE DID GREAT HE DID GREAT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND OUR
STAFF WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE
TESTIMONY.
THAT'S BEEN OFFERED TODAY AND
I'LL TURN THE MATTER BACK TO
WHAT YOU'RE LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR NOW MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
THE REVIEW OF THE BOARD FOR
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LANCE
AFFAIRS AND GEOLOGIST --
AGAIN WE HELP WILL HAVE A TOTAL
OF NO MORE THAN FIFTEEN MINUTES --
AND IF YOU CAN KIND OF JUST GET
INTO TO ADDRESS AGAIN ISSUES
NUMBER ONE TWO FOUR AND FIVE AS
LISTED IN OUR AGENDA --
AND AND AGAIN PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO INTRODUCE OURSELVES.
AND WE WILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE SOME.
COMMENTS.
AFTER YOUR PRESENTATION PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING HONORABLE CHAIRS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF.
MY NAME IS MOHAMMAD QURESHI I'M
A PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER AND THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD.
WITH ME TODAY ARE RICK MORE THE
BOARDS THAT COULD'VE OFFICER
NANCY EYES ALERT THE ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND ANDREW
HAMILTON PUBLIC MEMBER OF THE
BOARD.
WE APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE TO THE
COMMITTEE ON OUR BOARD.
DURING THE LAST FOUR YEARS AS
WELL AS PRESENT OUR PLANS FOR
THE FUTURE.
LICENSING OF LAND SURVEYORS
BEGAN IN EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THE
STATE'S SURVEYOR GENERAL.
LICENSING OF CIVIL ENGINEERING
AND THE REGULATION OF THE
PRACTICE OF CIVIL ENGINEERING
BEGAN IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE WITH THE
CREATION OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTRATION FOR CIVIL ENGINEERS.
FOLLOWING THE FAILURE OF THE
STAIN FRANCIS DAM.
EVEN IF IT IS KILEY GET INTO
YOUR OF YOUR THE BOARD --
HAS SUBMITTED THIS INFORMATION
TO TO US AND SO --
WE FORGET DIRECTLY INTO THE
ISSUES THAT WE CAN BE
EXPEDITIOUS OURS BUT I HEART
THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE
IS IT.
ASSISTANT AT THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER IN THE SYSTEM THANK YOU
FOR THE LONG TERM FUND
COMMISSION.
THE BOARDS EXPENDITURES HAVE
INCREASED OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS BY AN AVERAGE ABOUT 8% PER
YEAR.
THIS IS PRIMARILY DUE TO AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF STAFF
GENERAL INCREASES AND SALARY AND
BENEFITS FOR ALL STAFF.
AWFULLY EXPENDITURE EXPENDITURES
RELATING TO EXAMINATION
DEVELOPMENT AND PRO RATHER.
WHICH IN ITSELF HAS BEEN
AFFECTED BY INCREASES EMPLOYEE
STAFFS AND BENEFITS.
THE BOARD RECOGNIZES THAT IF THE
FISCAL STRUCTURE REMAINS
UNCHANGED IT WILL ENCOUNTER A
DEFICIT BEGINNING FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ADDITIONALLY
SINCE THE MERGER OF THE
GEOLOGISTS GEOPHYSICISTS COUNT
WITH THE BOARD THE ENGINEERS A
SERVER IS FUN THE BOARD HAS
RECOGNIZED THE FEES CHARGED TO
THE DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS.
ARE REQUIRES SO A LITTLE BIT
MORE STANDARDIZATION.
THE BOARD DIRECTED STAFF TO
CONDUCT A REVIEW OF SERVICES
PROVIDED --
SUCH AS LICENSE YOUR APPLICATION
PROCESS EXAM DEVELOPMENT FORSMAN
NEW A PROCESSING.
AND TO DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE
FEES IT SHOULD BE CHARGE FOR
THESE SERVICES TO SUPPORT
OVERALL OPERATIONS.
AT THE NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MEETING THE BOARD
APPROVED STAFF'S PROPOSED THREE
REVISIONS TO REGULATIONS.
THAT SPECIFIED EXACT FEES TO BE
PAID TO THE BOARD FOR THE
SERVICES.
STAFF IS PREPARING THE TO
INITIATE THAT RULE MAKING
PROCESS TO AMEND OF FEES WHAT
THE GOAL TO DO FEES WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THE BOARD EXPECTS
TO REVIEW THE FEE STRUCTURE
WITHIN THREE YEARS BEYOND THAT
EFFECTIVE DATE --
SO AS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ANY
NEW EFFICIENCIES EXPECTED THERE
WAS AS A RESULT OF OUR BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS.
ISSUE TWO LICENSE PROCESS TIME
LINES --
THERE'S FOUR MAJOR MILESTONES.
THAT LICENSEES ARE CANDIDATES
FOR LICENSURE MUST REACH OUR
MUST SATISFY TO COME LICENSES
ENGINEER SURVEYOR OR GEOLOGIST
IN CALIFORNIA.
TYPICALLY THOSE ARE TWO ACQUIRED
RECKLESS AND EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE PASS UP TO TWO
NATIONAL EXAMS APPLY FOR
LICENSURE WITH THE BOARD AND
PASS AN APPLET APPLICABLE STATE
EXAMS.
SINCE THE LAST SUNSET REVIEW THE
BOARD HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN SEPARATING THE
REQUIRED EXAMINATION CRITERIA
FROM THE LICENSE YOUR
APPLICATION PROCESS.
NOW A POTENTIAL CANDIDATE FOR
LICENSURE ONLY APPLIES TO THE
BOARD ONCE THE EVER ALREADY
ACQUIRED EXPERIENCE AND
EDUCATION AND AFTER THEY'VE
PASSED THE APPROPRIATE NATIONAL
EXAMS.
FURTHERMORE THAT WE WILL THE
BOARD BELIEVES THAT THIS ALLOWS
THE APPLICANT. TO FEAR WILL
PREPARE TO TAKE THE NATIONAL
EXAM NGUYEN THERE ARE WHEN THEY
WANT TO WHEN THEY BELIEVE
THEY'RE READY AND THEY NO LONGER
MUST WAIT FOR THE BOARDS
APPLICATION PROCESS TO THIS
CHANGE THE BOARD ONLY.
ONLY DIRECTLY INFLUENCES TO IN A
MAJOR MILESTONES MENTIONED.
THOSE RARE PRUE OF AN APPLICANT
FOR LICENSURE UPON RECEIPT OF A
COMPLETE APPLICATION AND THEN
OFFERING THE STATE EXAM SO WHERE
THOSE ARE REQUIRE.
THE BOARD DOES HAVE THEM PUT ON
THERE ARE FOR THE NATIONAL EXAMS
BUT DOES NOT DIRECTLY INFLUENCE
WINNER HOW OFTEN THEY ARE
OFFERED. FOR ENGINEERS AND
SURVEYORS APPROXIMATELY ONE
THIRD OF THE NATIONAL EXAMS ARE
CURRENTLY OFFERED VIA.
COMPUTER BASED TESTING.
EXAM THAT HIGH DEMAND HI
POPULATIONS.
ARE OR WILL BE OFFERED ON A YEAR
ROUND BASIS WHILE EXAMS WITH
LESS OF A DEMAND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE OFFERED ON SELECT DATES
NATIONWIDE.
ALL EXAMS FOR ENGINEERS LANCERS
NATIONAL EXAMS ARE EXPECTED BE
CONVERTED TO COMPUTER BASED
TESTING MY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
GEOLOGIST EXAMS ARE STILL
PRIMARILY OFFER TWICE A YEAR ON
PAPER.
THE BOARD IS ACTIVELY INVOLVED
IN LEADERSHIP LEVEL WITH AS BOG
THE NATIONAL SO ORGANIZATION
THAT DEVELOPS THE NATIONAL
GEOLOGY EXAMINATIONS. TO DEVELOP --
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR
TRANSITION OF THESE NATIONAL
EXAMS TO COMPUTER BASED TESTING.
IN TERMS OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS WITH THE PREVIOUSLY
DESCRIBED CHANGES THE BOARD HAS
ESTABLISHMENT TERRIBLE TOWARDS
NOTIFYING APPLICANT OF
ACCEPTABILITY OR INCOMPLETE.
WITHIN A THIRTY DAYTIME FRAME
AFTER RECEIPT OF THE APPLICATION.
CURRENTLY THIS CHANGES IN THE
PROCESS IS RESULTING IN A TIME
FRAME OF BETWEEN THIRTY TO SIXTY
DAYS ON AVERAGE AND IS HEAVILY
INFLUENCED BY THE BOARDS
RELIANCE ON OUTDATED APPLICATION
LICENSING DATABASE SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION THE BOARD REGULARLY
CONDUCTS NEVER GET OUT REACHING
A NEW PROCESS AS WELL AS HELPING
OUT KANSEN SURE APPLICATIONS ARE
COMPLETE.
WHEN IT INCOMPLETE APPLICATION
IS RECEIVED BOARD WORKS DIRECTLY
WITH THE APPLICANT TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION SO
THAT THEY CAN COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION?
THROUGH THE EVENTUAL ACCUSATION
ACQUISITION OF A NEW
COMPREHENSIVE APPLICATION
LICENSE AND SYSTEM THAT IS
CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY.
AND BY REGULAR PROCESS
VERIFICATION OR IMPROVEMENT
VALIDATION THE MORE THAN TWO SO
BATES ABILITY TO ACHIEVE ITS --
INTERNAL TIME FRAME GOALS.
UPON APPLICATION REVIEW REVIEW
APPROVAL SOME APPLICANTS MAY BE
REQUIRED TO PASS THE STATE
SPECIFIC EXAM UNIQUE CALIFORNIA
PRACTICE.
CURRENTLY ALL STATE SPECIFIC
EXAMS DEVELOP BY TOWARD OUR
OFFER BY COMPUTER BASED TESTING
HAVE BEEN SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THIS PROJECT
PROVIDES A CANDY WOULD
FLEXIBILITY AND CONVENIENCE OF
SCHEDULING EXAMINE A TIME
LOCATION OF THEIR CHOOSING WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THAT SECURITY IN
EXAMINATION OUR STANDARDIZATION
EXAMS ARE SECURE.
THOSE HIGHER DEMAND EXAMS ARE
OFFERED YEAR ROUND WHILE THE
REMAINING ONES ARE AGAIN OFFER
ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR TO PUT ON
SPECIFIC DATES AND LEVELS OF
DEMAND. FOR MANY OF THE BOARD'S
APPLICANTS SEEKING A LICENSE
THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE STATE
EXAMINATION COMPONENT.
THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS NOW
THE FINAL STEP IN MY CENTER.
THESE CHANGES MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY RESULTED IN LICENSES
NOW BE AN ISSUE BY THE BOARD UP
TO TWICE A MONTH RATHER THAN
TWICE A YEAR AND A PASSED.
CONSEQUENTLY THE BOARD FEELS
THAT IS TAKEN SIGNIFICANT
MEASURES TO THE STREAMLINED THE
STEPS TO ACHIEVE LICENSURE.
THERE ARE UNDER ITS CONTROL AND
INFLUENCE.
OF AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO NANCY EYES RESISTING
SECOND OFFICER TO ADDRESS ISSUE
FOR NINETY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR RELATES TO
ENFORCEMENT TIME LINES AND WE
WILL PROVIDE.
COMPLETE DETAILED RESPONSE IN A
WRITTEN RESPONSE REGARDING ALL
OF THE AREAS OF OUR ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS BUT TODAY I WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE BOARDS
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION. FOR DO BY ON THE
CASES THAT WE REFER TO THEM FOR
INVESTIGATION.
AND THE OVERALL H. AVERAGE AGE
OF THE BOARD'S INVESTIGATIONS
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY DISSED
DECREASED SINCE LAST SUNSET
REVIEW.
AND THE TIME LINES HAVE REMAINED
FAIRLY CONSTANT OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT ALL CASES ARE INVESTIGATED
BY THE BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT UNIT
STAFF WHO ARE ANALYSTS AND NOT
FIELD INVESTIGATORS.
ONLY A SMALL PORTION OF THOSE
CASES ARE REFERRED TO DFI TO
ASSIST THE BOARD STAFF WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
HOWEVER THE CASES THAT ARE
REFERRED TO DE OF I'D SCALE OF
OUR OVERALL CASES.
TYPICALLY THE CASES THAT ARE
REFERRED TO DEVALUE Và OF
ALLEGATIONS RELATING TO
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY.
SUCH AS ON LICENSE INDIVIDUALS
OPERATING BUSINESSES WITHOUT AN
APPROPRIATELY LICENSED PERSON
AND RESPONSIBLE CHARGE OF THE
BUSINESS OPERATIONS.
AS WELL AS MORE SERIOUS CASES
WHERE I LICENSE PEOPLE ARE
POSING AS LICENSEES.
DID OF THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
BOARDS LAWS REGARDING HIM MAY
OFFER PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
EXACTLY WHAT SERVICES REQUIRE
LICENSURE AND HOW BUSINESSES
MUST BE STRUCTURED.
THERE ARE NUANCES THAT MAYBE
OVERLOOKED BY INVESTIGATORS WHO
ARE NOT FULLY VERSED ON OUR LAWS.
OTHER CASES REFERRED TO THE OF
AYE INVOLVE THOSE REPORTS STAFF
LACKS SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
LOCATE INDIVIDUALS AND OBTAIN
DOCUMENTS.
GIVE AYE HAS THESE RESOURCES TO
LOCATE THE INDIVIDUALS AND
CONDUCT IN PERSON RATE
INTERVIEWS.
AS WELL AS OBTAINING DOCUMENTS
FROM INDIVIDUALS PRIVATE
BUSINESSES AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES.
BECAUSE OF THE TECHNICAL NATURE
OF OUR PROFESSIONS LAY PEOPLE
INCLUDING TRAINED INVESTIGATORS.
MAY NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH THE
TERMINOLOGY IS FOR THE TYPES OF
DOCUMENTS PRODUCED.
THESE ISSUES WHILE
UNDERSTANDABLE CAN LEAD TO
PROLONGED INVESTIGATIONS DUE TO
THE NEED FOR CLARIFICATION AND
FOLLOW AT IN DISCUSSIONS WITH T.
OF MY STAFF IT WAS AGREED THAT
IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO THEIR
INVESTIGATORS. FOR BOARD STAFF
TO PROVIDE TRAINING REGARDING
SPECIFIC ASPECTS OF OUR LAWS AND
THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF OUR
PROFESSIONS.
SO THAT THE INVESTIGATORS WOULD
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THESE ISSUES BEFORE BEGINNING
THEIR INVESTIGATION.
BOARD STAFF IS WORKING WITH
DIVIDE TO DEVELOP THE TRAINING
WITH THE GOAL OF PRESENTING IT
TO THE INVESTIGATORS IN THE LATE
SPRING OR EARLY SUMMER OF THIS
YEAR.
NOW I WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE REGARDING
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY AGAIN WE WILL PROVIDE A
MUCH MORE DETAILED WRITTEN
RESPONSE BUT TODAY I WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE BOARDS OUTREACH
EFFORTS REGARDING UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY.
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY IS OF GREAT
CONCERN TO THE BORDER.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE RAPID
GROWTH OF TECHNOLOGY RANGING
FROM WIDESPREAD USE OF THE
INTERNET TO CONDUCT BUSINESS. TO
THE ACTUAL TOOLS USED TO PERFORM
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERING LAND
SURVEYING GEOLOGY AND GEOPHYSICS.
COMPANIES NOT PROPERLY OVERSEEN
BY LICENSEES ARE CONDUCTING
BUSINESSES THROUGH WEBSITES AND
COMMUNICATING VIA CELLPHONE AN
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION.
THIS CAUSES DIFFICULTY IN
LOCATING THE RESPONSIBLE
INDIVIDUALS AS THERE IS OFTEN NO
PHYSICAL ADDRESS INCLUDED IN THE
CONTACT INFORMATION ON THE
WEBSITE.
FURTHERMORE THE BOARD HAS NO
AUTHORITY TO SHUT DOWN WEBSITES
AND CELL PHONES. ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON FORMS OF UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY THAT IS BROUGHT TO THE
BOARD'S INTENTION INVOLVES
LICENSE CONTRACTORS WHO MAY BE
UNKNOWINGLY EXCEEDING THEIR
LICENSE AUTHORITY.
BY PERFORMING PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERING LAND SURVEYING
GEOLOGY SERVICES ON PROJECTS.
PARTICULARLY IN THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED TOOLS.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
IN THE PAST TO PUBLICIZE THE
LIMITATIONS OF LICENSE
CONTRACTORS AN OFFER EDUCATION.
REGARDING THE RESTRICTIONS OF
THE USE OF PARTICULAR TOOLS SUCH
AS GPS DRONES.
AND GROUND PENETRATING RADAR
ALSO OUR AND THE LIMITATIONS AND
EXEMPTIONS PROVIDED BY THE BOARD
STATUTES. ONE OF THE METHODS
THAT THE BOARD USES TO
DISCOURAGE UNLICENSED ACTIVITY
INCLUDES OUTRAGE TO BOTH
LICENSED AND UNLICENSED
INDIVIDUALS.
AS WELL AS TO THE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THAT DEAL WITH THE
PROFESSIONS THE BOARD REGULATES.
WE DO THIS TO EDUCATE THEM
REGARDING POTENTIAL AREAS OF
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY INCLUDING
THE UNKNOWING PRACTICE BY
LICENSED INDIVIDUALS.
DURING MEETINGS AN OUTREACH
EVENTS WITH VARIOUS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS SPORTS STAFF OF
FOCUSED ON IDENTIFYING FOR
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS.
WAYS IN WHICH THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE BOARD'S
EFFORTS TO CURTAIL UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY.
LICENSEES WHO DISCOVER SUCH
ACTIVITY ARE ENCOURAGED TO FILE
FORMAL COMPLAINTS AND INCLUDE
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE RATHER THAN
PASSING ALONG UNSUBSTANTIATED
ALLEGATIONS AND INFORMAL
CONVERSATIONAL SETTING OR
CORRESPONDENT.
SELECT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME FROM ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER KRISTIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
I WAS IN HERE FOR THE LATTER
PART OF IT --
BUT MOSTLY INTERESTED IN THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE JUST MADE
ABOUT --
ABOUT UNLICENSED ACTIVITY.
HAS A HAS THE BOARD CONSIDERED I
KNOW YOU REACHED OUT --
TO SEAL --
THE YOU KNOW THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD --
HAVE YOU ALSO REACHED OUT TO
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES WHERE
PERMITS ARE BEING ISSUED AND
EDUCATED PLANNING --
DIVISIONS WITH AND LOCAL MEANS
WHEN PLANS COME FORWARD THIS MAY
NOT CATCH THOSE THAT ARE
UNLICENSED THAT ARE UNSCRUPULOUS
AND THEY AREN'T EVEN GOING TO
GET A PERMIT BUT FOR YOU
MENTIONED THERE ARE SOME
CONTRACTORS THAT MAY BE.
OVER REACHING THEIR THE
BOUNDARIES OF THEIR LICENSE.
AND SO PLANS ARE ARE PUT IN FOR
A PERMIT.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
STAFFS COULD RECOGNIZE AREAS IF
THEY WERE EDUCATED TO BE ABLE TO
KNOW.
THIS NEEDS TO HAVE AN ENGINEER
LOOK AT IT OR A YOU KNOW SOME
SOME TYPE OF STAMP --
HAS THAT EVER GOING FORTH TO
HELP EDUCATE PLANNING STAFFS
THAT LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES --
YES WE WE HAVE WORKED --
MORE RIGOROUSLY IN THE PAST AND
ARE LOOKING INTO DOING IT AGAIN
WORKING WITH --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
REGARDING --
WHEN I LICENSES NEEDED --
THEY ARE THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS ARE VERY GOOD ABOUT
KNOWING.
WHEN AND PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
LICENSES NEEDED ON --
BUILDING DESIGN PLANS --
THEY OFTEN ARE THE ONES WHO WILL
ALERT US WHEN IT APPEARS AN
UNLICENSED PERSON.
MAYBE UNLAWFULLY USING A
LICENSEE STAM OR THAT.
A LICENSEE MAY BE WORKING WITH
AN UNLICENSED PERSON.
AND SIMPLY STAMPING THE PLANS
WITHOUT REVIEW. TO MEET THE
RESPONSIBLE CHARGE LAWS WE'VE
HAD CASES WHERE.
WE'VE DISCOVERED THAT LICENSEES
WOULD SIGN AND SAIL PLANS. FOR A
BOTTLE OF SCOTCH SO WE WE HAVE
WORKED WITH THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS ON THOSE TYPES OF
CASES -- I
THINK.
WITH REGARD TO LIKE THE LICENSE
CONTRACTORS --
IT'S THE WORK THEY'RE DOING ON
THEIR CONSTRUCTION SITES.
BASED ON THE NEW TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND THEY DON'T
REALIZE THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
FALL ARE AND HOW THEY USE SOME
OF THAT EQUIPMENT. TO DO THEIR
WORK THAT THEY'VE NOW CROSSED
OVER INTO SUCH THINGS AS THE
PROFESSION OF LAND SURVEYING.
AND SO THAT IS WHERE WE HAVE
TRIED. TO IT WE HAVE WORKED IN
THE PAST A WE'RE HOPING TO WORK
AGAIN WITH THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD --
TO HAVE.
THEM HELP US REACH OUT TO THEIR
LICENSEES --
THROUGH THEIR ENFORCEMENT AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS WOULD YOU
HAPPEN TO KNOW WHEN THE LAST
TIME WAS THAT YOU DID AN
OUTREACH EFFORT EDUCATING
GENERAL CONCORD.
ALL CONTRACTORS.
ON THAT -- I
WOULD SAY THAT MY DIRECT.
DIRECTLY WITH --
LICENSE CONTRACTORS IT'S BUT
IT'S PRIDE IN A FEW YEARS BY --
THIS LAST YEAR THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS ACTUALLY LOCAL AGENCIES
BECAUSE OF THEIR CONTRACTING
METHODOLOGIES YES WE HAVE
CONTRACTORS ENGINEERS AND
SURVEYORS TO TRY TO HELP THEM
RECOGNIZE WHERE THE LIMITATIONS
OF ALL THE PRACTICES AREN'T ARE
TRYING TO HELP THEM.
NOT PUT ANY LICENSE MEMBER
WHICHEVER BOARD IT IS INTO A
COMPROMISING POSITION WOULD
RATHER TRY TO AVOID THAT AND I
WILL TELL YOU THAT I I
PERSONALLY APPRECIATE THOSE
NOTICES WHEN THEY COME IN THE
MAIL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CAN YOU MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NONE AT ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE PODIUM IN THE
MIKE IN THE GAME.
NAME IN AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JOSHUA SHAW
WITH SCHNEIDER INTO YOU
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA AND
NEVADA CIVIL ENGINEERS AND LAND
SURVEYORS ASSOCIATION.
A SMALL SITUATION OF COMPANIES
THAT PROVIDE LAND SURVEYING --
PRACTICES --
WHO WORK WITH A MASTER AGREEMENT
WE SIGNED WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF OPERATING ENGINEERS
WHOLEHEARTEDLY?
SUPPORT EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET
OF THIS BOARD NECESSARY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AS WELL AS RUN A GREAT LICENSING
PROGRAM WE DO WANT TO CONTINUE
TO TALK WITH YOU ALL ABOUT SOME
OF THE UNLICENSED ACTIVITY WITH
THAT MISS EISLER MISSED MORE
TALKED WITH THIS IMMIGRATION
ABOUT.
WE ARE CO SPONSORING WITH THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS LEGISLATION
ADDITIONAL TOOLS IN THAT AREA
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND THE
BOARD AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRS MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JENNIFER HORN I WITH THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES CALIFORNIA WE ACC
CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE THE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE
WITH THE BOARD.
AND WILL BE PUTTING THE SUNSET
REVIEW BILL THROUGH OUR REVIEW
PROCESS ONCE THAT'S BEEN
COMPLETED WILL BE SURE TO SHARE
ANY OFFICIAL COMMENTS OR
POSITIONS WITH THE COMMITTEE.
AS WELL AS THE BOARD AT THAT
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS OF MY
NAME'S CONSCIENCE KEY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA --
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO COME
AND ENDORSE THE RE AUTHORIZATION
OF OUR LICENSING BOARD --
JUST ONE FOLLOW UP ON NOTE ON
RECOMMENDATION EIGHTEEN FROM THE
LAST SUNSET REVIEW --
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY REQUIRES
THAT THE DESIGN OF KATE TWELVE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE QUEUE CARE
HOSPITALS --
BE DONE BY LICENSE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS --
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED THOSE
PRACTICE RESTRICTIONS FOLLOWING
DAMAGE TO SCHOOLS IN THE
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE LONG BEACH
EARTHQUAKE AND DAMAGE TO
HOSPITALS IN THE NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE NORTHRIDGE QUAKE --
WE DON'T THINK WE NEED TO WAIT --
FOR ANOTHER DISASTER TO DECIDE
WHICH OTHER IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
STRUCTURES --
DESERVE --
TO BE DESIGNED OR SHOULD BE
DESIGNED BY ENGINEERS WITH A
MORE SPECIALIZED --
EDUCATION AND TRAINING --
BUT THAT SAID WE DO THINK THE
BOARD -- DID
A CREDIBLE JOB OF ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE LAST TIME AROUND --
AND WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
SPA.
GOOD MORNING A MEMBERS RICHARD
MARX AND PACIFIC ADVOCACY GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF CIVIL ENGINEERS.
NINETEEN THOUSAND CIVIL
ENGINEERS AND PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE EXTENSION
OF THE BOARD WE THINK THEY'RE
DOING AN EXCELLENT JOB THANK YOU.
TIM CRIMMINS --
INTERNATIONAL OF OPERATING
JUNIORS IN YOU HEARD MR SHALL WE
ARE THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL
OF HIM.
NOPE HOPEFULLY THE BILL CLARIFY
WHEN AND WHERE YOU NEED A
LICENSE --
IT IS GET DOES GET VERY
TECHNICAL FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC
AND IT'S FOR IT IT SPREAD ITSELF
ACROSS A KIND OF A WHITE
JURISDICTION IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING
DRAMATICALLY SO SO WHAT DO WE DO
WANT TO CLARIFY WHEN WHERE IT'S
NEEDED -- WE
ARE HAVING TROUBLE ENFORCEMENT
OF THE BOARD IS WITH A VERY
SHORT STAFFED TRYING TO HELP US
AND THEY'VE BEEN VERY GOOD ABOUT
IT -- AND I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT.
STAFF ARE SELDOM GUN RUN
CONSTRUCTION SITE EVERY DAY
CHECKING FOR WEIGHT VIOLATIONS
RIGHT ALONGSIDE VIOLATION THE
LAW AND WE HAVE.
AND WE'RE WILLING AND READY
HAPPY TO BRING TO THE BOARD
PRESET.
INVESTIGATED CASES WE CAN HELP --
EXPEDITE THEIR FORSMAN PROCESS
AND THE MORNING MEREDITH AS LAKE --
REPRESENTING OUR WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ENGINEERING GEOLOGIST AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
OVERSIGHT AND OFFER THE
ASSOCIATION AS A REF.
A RESOURCE IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING G. V. AIRS --
WITH.
ASSOCIATION OF THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL IN AN ENGINEERING
GEOLOGIST NEW CLIENT HERE AND
ECHO THE REMARKS OF OF MEREDITH
HERE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH COMMITTEE WITH THE WITH THE
BOARD.
AND APPRECIATE THE THOROUGH
BACKGROUND PAPER THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
OUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA LAND
SURVEYORS ASSOCIATION JUST WANT
TO REITERATE WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN
SAID ABOUT THE UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY AND WANT TO WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THE BOARD
ON ADDRESSING THAT.
TECHNOLOGY IS THE SORT OF
OVERTAKING THE LINES OF
AUTHORITY BETWEEN THESE LICENSES
AND IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME.
SEE NONE ANY FOR A FINAL
CONCLUDING REMARKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AGAIN.
MUCH APPRECIATED NOW TO TURN
THIS -- BACK
OVER TO SHERMAN GLACIER.
THANK YOU CHAIR LOW WE WANT TO
INVITE UP THE CEMETERY AND
FUNERAL BUREAU.
IN THAT BRIEF OVERVIEW AND
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT BEEN
REYES AND STAFF REPORT.
IS -- IS
DEAN.
OF FEEL HERE PLEASE COME UP
[inaudible]
OTHER.
OUR TIME S SHORT IN ONE GIVEN
THE BENEFIT OF THE FULL REVIEWS
SO PLEASE START WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
COGNIZANT OF THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS ARE BE VERY QUICK IN
INTRODUCING MISSED GEN SANCHEZ.
THE SOME MORE SERVICE THE BUREAU
CHIEF FOR THE CEMETERY AND
FUNERAL FOR SEVEN YEARS.
RETIRED IN NOVEMBER AFTER THIRTY
FOUR YEARS OF SERVICE.
WE ARE THANKFUL THAT SHE STAYED
ON LONG ENOUGH TO COMPLETE THE
CENTER REPORT TO THE COMMITTEES.
WE DID AN EXHAUSTIVE SEARCH FOR
A NEW BUREAU CHIEF INCLUDING
SENDING THE JOB POSTING TO THE
INDUSTRY.
STAKEHOLDERS AND TO COLLEGES IN
THIS AREA.
WE ALTERNATELY FOUND THE BEST
CANDIDATE RIGHT HERE AT THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
JANICE ON CHEST.
MOST RECENTLY THE LICENSING
CHIEF AT THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY.
ALSO LIKE TO MENTION THAT SHE
STARTED MAIL ROOM IN THE
DEPARTMENT.
I WANT TO THANK THE VERY PEOPLE
STAFF OF THE BUREAU ESPECIALLY
SANDRA PATTERSON WHO STEPPED IN
TO KEEP THE BUREAU RUNNING FOR
TWO MONTHS DURING OUR TREATMENT.
WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
T. SUCH AS THANK YOU DEAN
CONGRADULATIONS GINA.
IS THIS ONE OKAY.
MY NAME IS GINA SANCHEZ THE
NEWLY APPOINTED CHIEF OF THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL BUREAU I
WAS APPOINTED ON FEBRUARY
TWENTIETH AND I'M HONORED TO
REPRESENT THE BEER ON THE
CONSUMERS WE SERVE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK DIRECTOR
FEEL FOR BEING HERE SUPPORTING
THE RIO TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
FUNERAL DIRECTORS AND PALMER'S
WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE CEMETERY BOARD IN.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES LEGISLATIVE
DISCUSSION REGARDING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF TWO SEPARATE
BOARDS LED TO THE CREATING OF
THE CEMETERY AND FUNERAL BUREAU.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AS A
RESULT OF THE BUREAU'S LAST
SENSE THAT BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE EIGHTY MERGE THE BEER AS TWO
SEPARATE PRACTICE TAX.
INTO THE CEMETERY AND FUNERAL
ACT AND ALSO MERGE THE BUREAU'S
TWO SEPARATE FUNDS INTO ONE FINE
NOW KNOWN AS A CEMETERY AND
FUNERAL FINDS.
IF YOU'RE CURRENTLY HAS TWENTY
THREE POINT FIVE AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS CONSISTING OF NINE
FULL TIME STAFF LOCATED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND FOURTEEN POINT FIVE OFFICE
STAFF LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO.
TODAY THE BUREAU LICENSES
REGULATES AND INVESTIGATES
COMPLAINTS AGAINST THIRTEEN
DIFFERENT LICENSING CATEGORIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
TOTALING APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN
THOUSAND LICENSEES.
THE LICENSING CATEGORIES INCLUDE
FUNERAL ESTABLISHMENTS FUNERAL
DIRECTORS PRIVATELY OWNED
CEMETERIES AND CREMATORIUMS
CEMETERY AND CREMATORIUM
MANAGERS ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL
LICENSES WITHIN THE INDUSTRY.
EACH YEAR THERE ARE OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
REQUIRE THE SERVICES OF ONE OR
MORE OF OUR LICENSEES.
THE BUREAU REGULATES NEARLY
EVERY ASPECT OF THE LICENSE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL INDUSTRIES.
SPECIFIC TO EXPEDITIONARY
OVERSIGHT --
MONITORS THE PRE NEED FUNERAL
TRUST FUNDS CEMETERY IN DOWN
MEDICARE TRUST FUNDS AND
CEMETERY SPECIAL CARE TRUST
FUNDS TOTALING MORE THAN TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
BUREAU STAFF REVIEW ANNUAL
REPORTS AND FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
AND PERFORM SITE VISITS AND
EXAMINATIONS TO ENSURE THESE
TRUST FUNDS ARE ADMINISTERED
APPROPRIATELY AND IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMERS.
THE BUREAU HAS STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE THE
LICENSING AND PRACTICE ACT IN
THE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS CODE
RELATING TO THE FUNERAL CEMETERY
AND CREMATORY INDUSTRIES.
THE BEER ALSO HAS JURISDICTION
OVER SPECIFIED SECTIONS OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE DEALING
WITH HUMAN REMAINS CEMETERY AND
CREMATORY PROVISIONS.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA GET TO THE
ISSUES RIGHT WE WANT TO MAKE DO
YOU WANT ME TO GET STRAIGHT.
SO I SORRY I MISUNDERSTOOD I OWE
EVERYTHING HAVING TO DO WE HAVE
THE HAVE YOU A LITTLE THE GOOD
WORK THAT --
THAT YOU GUYS.
TO I DO LIKE TO PRACTICE SO I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER TWO RELATED TO THE IN
DOWN THE CARE FUNDS WHICH I WAS
JUST SPEAKING ABOUT --
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY
DIRECTOR THE BUREAU TO CONDUCT A
STUDY IN ORDER TO DETERMINE IF
IN DOWN THE CARE LEVELS AND EACH
LICENSE CEMETERY ARE SUFFICIENT
TO COVER.
THE COST OF FUTURE MAINTENANCE
IN DOWN THE CARE CEMETERIES
DEPOSIT FUNDS INTO AN ENDEMIC
CARE TRUST. FOR EACH GRAVER
OTHER INTERMENT SPACE THEY SELL.
THE DEPOSITS MAKE UP THE CORE
PRINCIPLE OF THE TRUST AND STATE
LAW REQUIRES THE TRUSTEE TO
INVEST THIS PRINCIPLE.
THE LONG RUN INTENT IS TO BUILD
ENOUGH PRINCIPLE TO ENSURE
INCOME GENERATED FROM THE
INVESTMENTS.
PAYS FOR CEMETERY MAINTENANCE
AFTER THE CEMETERIES OF SOLD ALL
OF THEIR INTERMENT SPACES.
OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
CEMETERY. TWENTY ONE EARN ENOUGH
INCOME FROM PRINCIPLE
INVESTMENTS AND WILL REQUIRE
ONLY MINIMAL IN DOWN THE CARE
FUND GROWTH TO ENSURE LONGER
INSUFFICIENCY. HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN DO NOT EARN ENOUGH
INCOME FROM PRINCIPLE
INVESTMENTS AND LONGER
INSUFFICIENCY REQUIRE MORE
SIGNIFICANT TRUSTS GROWTH.
AND FORTY TWO DO NOT EARN ENOUGH
INCOME FROM INVESTMENTS AND MEAN
TAKE TO MAINTAIN THE SPACES THEY
HAVE ALREADY SOLD.
ALONG WITH SUFFICIENCY IS NOT
LIKELY IT SHOULD BE MENTIONED
HOWEVER THAT THIRTY FOUR OF
THESE FORTY TWO WERE ESTABLISHED
BEFORE IN DOWN THE CARE TRUSTS
WERE REQUIRED.
SO MANY HAVE SOLD SPACES PRIOR
TO THAT BEING ESTABLISHED.
THE BEER IS COMMITTED TO
PARTNERING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO BEGIN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RAISING THE
IN DOWN THE CARE DEPOSIT RATES
[inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
IT MAY BE NECESSARY TO CONDUCT A
FOLLOW UP STUDY AS A FUTURE
STUDY MAY BE BETTER INFORMED IF
THE BUREAU IS ABLE TO GATHER
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
FROM LICENSEES AND STAKEHOLDERS.
THIS ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WILL
NOT ONLY PROVIDE A FULL REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT WILL ALSO ASSIST THE BUREAU
IN ITS OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES ENSURING THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF IN DOWN THE
CARE TRUSTS.
I STATED IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE THIS IS A MATTER OF
PUBLIC PROTECTION TO PRESERVE
AND KEEP CEMETERIES FROM
BECOMING I'M CAPT.
AND PLACES OF REPROACH AND
DESOLATION IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH THEY ARE SITUATED.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE REGARDING THE
RECENT COST ANALYSIS OF THE
BUREAU'S LICENSING FEES.
IN TWO THOUSAND LEGISLATION
CREATED WHAT IS TODAY THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL RURAL.
AT THAT TIME THE STATUTORY FEET
AUTHORITY WAS ALSO TRANSFERRED
TO THE BUREAU HOWEVER THE
PREVIOUSLY ESTABLISHED BE CAPS
REMAIN THE SAME.
SINCE ITS ESTABLISHMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND THE BUREAU HAS NOT HAD
ANY FEE INCREASES AND ACCORDING
TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
WEBSITE DURING THIS TIME THE
CONSUMER PRICE INSTEAD INDEX.
HAS INCREASED BY GOODS AND
SERVICES 49%.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
BUREAU CONTRACTED WITH AN
OUTSIDE VENDOR TO CONDUCT THE
FEES STUDY TO ENSURE THE BUREAU
WAS FULLY ACCOUNTING FOR ALL
COSTS.
AND RECOVERING ADEQUATE REVENUES
TO BE REIMBURSED FOR ITS
EXPENSIVE THIS EXPENSES THIS
ACTION WAS INITIATED IN RESPONSE
TO CONCERN THAT THE BUREAU'S
EXPENDITURES RECEIPT EXCEEDED
ITS REVENUE.
CAUSING THE BUREAU TO BE
STRUCTURALLY IN BALANCE IT WAS
PROJECTED TO BECOME PHYSICALLY
INSOLVENT AND BUDGET YOUR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THE REPORT
ESTABLISH A PRICING SCENARIO
THAT BETTER REFLECTED THE TRUE
CROSS TO FREEZE.
UP FEES TO PERFORM THE BUREAU'S
FUNCTION AND HELP ENSURE
SUSTAINABLE REGULATORY PROGRAM.
THE FINDINGS IN THE REPORT
CONCLUDED THAT THE BUREAU WAS
NOT ACCOUNTING FOR AND
RECOVERING ADEQUATE REVENUE TO
FULLY FUND THE BUREAU'S COST.
THE BUREAU HAS A HISTORY OF
FINANCIAL OF CONSERVATIVE
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT AND
CONTINUES TO OPERATE AS SUCH
THIS IS A LOT OF THE BUREAU TO
REMAIN SOLVENT BUT DOES NOT
RESOLVE THE STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE.
AND CONTINUED DECLINE IN THE
BUREAU SPINE CONDITION MONTHS IN
RESERVE.
IF THE BUREAU IS GRETA IS
GRANTED THE STATURE RATE
INCREASE OF THE FEE CAP.
STAFF WILL PREPARE A REGULATORY
RULEMAKING FILE AS NECESSARY TO
PURSUE INCREMENTAL INCREASES TO
THE BUREAU'S FEE SCHEDULE.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
IN REGARDS TO BREEZE.
AS REPORTED IN THE BUREAU'S LAST
AND SAID BETWEEN THE TWO
SEPARATE SPECIAL FUNDS THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH BREEZE CAME TO
APPROXIMATELY NINETY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AS A FISCAL YEAR.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE ORIGINAL
TOTAL PROJECTED COSTS FOR BREEZE
WAS 200-580-00700 SEVENTY EIGHT
DOLLARS.
AND THE TOTAL COST MEANT BY THE
BUREAU TO DATE IS. 200-610-00500
EIGHTY THREE DOLLARS WE WILL NOT
BE RECUPERATED FOR THESE COSTS
AS THIS MONEY REPRESENTS AN
INVESTMENT MADE BY THE BUREAU
THAT IS INFORMING OUR WORK AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. TO A FUTURE IT
SYSTEM.
WAS NO LONGER CONTRIBUTING TO
ANY COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH PRES
AND DO NOT ANTICIPATE ANY FUTURE
COSTS.
UNLESS THE BUREAU IS INTEGRATED
INTO BREEZE AS PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN.
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE OF THE
BUREAU REQUIRE STAFF TO USE TO
LEGACY SYSTEMS DATABASES TO
PERFORM THEIR DUTIES.
THE CURRENT SYSTEMS DO NOT MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE BUREAU IN THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND A
MODERN SYSTEM WOULD BETTER SERVE
OUR LICENSEES AND STAFF.
AS PART OF THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN THE BEER WAS
ALREADY DEVELOPED A PROJECT
CHARTER.
HI AND A REPORT TO IDENTIFIES
BUSINESS PROCESSES PRIOR TO THE
END OF LAST YEAR.
THE BUREAU IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT BEGAN PROCESS
MAPPING ENFORCEMENT HAS ITS
FIRST STEP.
SINCE MY APPOINTMENT AS OF
FEBRUARY TWENTIETH I'VE ALREADY
MET WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TEAM.
AND OF SCHEDULED MY FIRST
MEETING WITH THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN TEAM.
THE CALL FOR COMPLETE
IMPLEMENTATION IS TWENTY TWENTY
TWO HOWEVER I DO ANTICIPATE THE
BUREAU IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS PRIOR TO THAT.
SUCH AS THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CREDIT CARD PAY.
I AM REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS PROCESS IN SECURING AN
UPDATED I. T. SYSTEM CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING OUR LICENSEES AND EASY
AND SEAMLESS APPLICATION RENEWAL
PROCESS.
AS A BETTER WAY TO SUPPORT THEM
AS THEY ASSIST CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMER.
SORRY JUST JUST A CLASS.
NEXT MOVING ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
REGARDING THE REGULATION OF PET
CREMATORIUM.
THIS IS A NEW ISSUE RAISED BY
CONSTITUENTS TO THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD IN REGARDS TO THE
CREMATION OVER TO PASS.
WE SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
CONSTITUENT FOR A LOSS AND ANY
HARDSHIP SHE EXPERIENCE WHEN THE
PETS WERE CREMATED.
CURRENTLY PRAC CREMATIONS ARE
NOT REGULATED IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE BEER WAS NOT RECEIVED ANY
COMPLAINTS TO WE KNOW OF ANY
OTHER CONCERNS IN THIS AREA TO
DATE.
IF YOU'RE A LICENCES CREMATORY
IS THAT ARE CONTRACTED BY
FUNERAL ESTABLISHMENTS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR HUMAN
REMAINS.
THE CONSUMER PAYS THE FUNERAL
ESTABLISHMENT DIRECTLY FOR THESE
SERVICES.
FROM WHAT THE BROKEN TELL IT
APPEARS CRAP HIM CREMATIONS WORK
IN THE SAME WAY AND SERVICES CAN
BE CONTRACTOR THAT NERI OFFICE.
THAT BEING SAID THE BUREAU IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD IS
REQUESTING TIME TO RESEARCH AND
PERFORM A DEEPER DIVE INTO THIS
AREA PRIOR TO ANY LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES.
THE BUREAU AND THE BATTERY
MEDICAL BOARD HAVE ALREADY
CONVENE ONE MEETING ON THIS AND
WE PLAN TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
ON THIS ISSUE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD.
AND WILL REPORT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEES WITHIN A YEAR ON THIS
ISSUE.
LASTLY MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN THE MAINTENANCE OF
CEMETERIES.
THE CEMETERY PRESENTS ITS OWN
UNIQUE CHALLENGES RELATING TO
PROPERTY MAINTENANCE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH EXISTING LAW THE
BUREAU CONDUCTS ANNUAL
UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS OF EACH
LICENSE CEMETERY.
AND WE ARE CONSISTENT IN MEETING
THIS MANDATE.
I SPECIFIED IN REGULATION THE
CARE AND MAINTENANCE OF EACH
CEMETERY MAY VARY DEPENDING ON
THE CEMETERY SIZE LOCATION
TOPOGRAPHY AND TYPE OF
INTERMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY RELATING TO PIERCE
BROTHERS PAHALA MEMORIAL PARK
WHICH I WILL REFER TO HIS PEERS
BROTHERS.
THIS PROPERTY IS OVER ONE
HUNDRED EIGHT OF GRAVES AND
HEADSTONES AND MARKERS.
WHEN THE BUREAU RECIEVE THE
INITIAL COMPLAINT REFERENCE IN
THE ISSUE THE PROPERTY WAS
ISSUED A WARNING LETTER WHICH IS
NOT A GAME THE GATE A FINER
PENALTY? FOR FAILURE TO PERFORM
MAINTENANCE I'VE IT CEMETERY.
AS THE COMPLAINT WAS AND
SATISFIED WITH THE OUTCOME THE
BUREAU RE OPEN THIS COMPLAINT
AND IT WAS DETERMINED THAT THE
CEMETERY WAS TAKING NECESSARY
STEPS TO COMPLY WITH THE
CEMETERY MAINTENANCE STANDARDS
AND NO ADDITIONAL ACTION WAS
TAKEN.
THE FILE WAS CLOSED FOR A SECOND
TIME ON JUNE IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN ADDITIONAL
TO NORMAL MAINTENANCE THERE ARE
OUTSIDE CONTRIBUTING FACTORS
LIKE THE RECENT YEARS LONG
DROUGHT.
AND THAT HAS MADE SOIL AT SOME
TENTS CEMETERIES HOSPITABLE TO
THE RUN POPULATION.
EVEN WITH INCREASED EFFORTS
PIERCE BROTHERS HAS AN ONGOING
STRUGGLE TO CONTROL BERMAN
PROBLEMS AND KEEP THE DIRT FROM
BURNING RODENTS OFF MARKERS.
AS MUCH OF THE IMMEDIATELY
SURROUNDING AREAS PRIVATE
RESIDENCES.
THE PEST CONTROL COMPANY IS
LIMITED ON TREATMENT OPTIONS DUE
TO THE REGULATION OF CHEMICAL
USE NEAR HOUSING.
HERE'S BROTHER IS CURRENTLY
ASSIGNING A GROUNDS CREW TO COMB
THE ONE HUNDRED ACRE PROPERTY IN
AN EFFORT TO REMOVE GO FOR DIRT
PILES AND REPAIR MARKERS AND HAD
STONE'S.
THEY ALSO PROVIDE VISITING
FAMILIES WITH A MONTHLY
NEWSLETTER MOWING SCHEDULE
MEMORIAL TRIMMING SCHEDULE AND A
FLOWER PLACEMENT CALENDAR.
THE BUREAU IS DILIGENTLY
MONITORING THESE EFFORTS AND
WILL INITIATE HEIGHTENED
DISCIPLINE SHOULD PIERCE
BROTHERS FAILED TO FOLLOW THE
LAW.
THE BILL CONTINUES TO WORK WITH
ALL LICENSE CEMETERIES TO ENSURE
THEY ARE HEARING TO ME THAT
STANDARDS ALL THE WHILE
CONTINUING TO MAINTAIN OVERSIGHT
OF THE LICENSEES.
THE BUREAU MUST REMAIN COGNIZANT
OF THE FACT THAT EXTREME
MEASURES OF REVOCATION.
OF A LICENCE FOR CEMETERY WOULD
REMOVE YOUR OVERSIGHT.
THAT IS WHY BUREAU STAFF WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH THE LICENSEE AND
PRACTICE OF PROGRESSIVE
DISCIPLINE MODEL IN ORDER TO
BRING THEM INTO COMPLIANCE.
THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY
TODAY I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE THIS
BODY AND PROVIDE INSIGHT INTO
THE IMPORTANT WORK THE BUREAU
DOES TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS.
ESPECIALLY IN THEIR TIME OF THE
MOST CRITICAL NEED.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEES AND HUMBLY ASK
THAT YOU EXTEND THE BUREAU SENSE
THAT FOR ANOTHER FOUR YEARS.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISS AN REVIEW OF
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARENTS YOUR TODAY --
ONE OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE IS
FOR MILITARY.
WIN -- THE
FAMILY REQUESTS CREMATION AND
OUT AT SEA.
THE ISSUE THERE IS --
HOW DO WE ARE SURE OF THE FAMILY
WHAT IS THE PROCESS YOU THAT
THERE IS A MIXTURE --
IN THE PROCESS AND SO ON AND
WHAT REGULATIONS DO YOU HAVE IN
PLACE.
THAT IN EFFECT THAT IF.
IF THE DEPARTURE --
VIOLATED ANY PURSE.
I CAN SAY THAT ARE YOU JUST WHEN
YOU SPOKE OF MAKE SURE MAKE SURE
OF HUMAN REMAINS BETWEEN THOSE
TWO TWO PEOPLE --
SPECIFIC TO THE PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES TAKEN BY THE BOARD IT
IS REQUIRED THAT LICENSE
CEMETERY MUST MAINTAIN RECORDS.
OF INTERMENTS OWNERSHIP OF ALL
PLOT SOLD ACCURATE PLOT MAX AND
THE ARE AND AND A LIST OF THOSE
WHO ARE CREMATED --
KEEPING A LOT OF THOSE WHICH ARE
SUBMITTED AN ANNUAL REPORTS TO
THE BUREAU --
IF AT ANY TIME THE BUREAU IS
MADE AWARE OF A COMPLAINT
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH AN
INSPECTION OF ONE OF OUR BUREAU
STAFF FOR COMPLETE FROM THE
PUBLIC.
I INVESTIGATION IS OPENED AND A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION IS TO
DOWN TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY.
VIOLATIONS OF LAW AT THAT TIME
AS I SAID WE DO --
PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINE MODEL
WHERE WE TRY TO WORK WITH THE
LICENSEE AND MEDIATE WITH THE
CONSUMER --
DEPENDING ON THE AGREE JUST MISS
OF THE VIOLATION OF COURSE THAT
WOULD DETERMINAR SPECIFIC ACTION
AND IS A COMMON PRACTICE THAT
ONE OF THE STAFF MEMBERS FROM
THE CEMETERY.
WITH A COMPANY THE FAMILY OUT TO
SEE -- AND
DEPOSITING THE THE REMAINS THE
ASHES OUT THERE.
I'M I'M CERTAIN OF OF THAT
RELATION I COULD LOOK INTO THAT
AND GIVE THAT TO YOU IN A
WRITTEN RESPONSE.
MAKE SURE IT'S DONE PROPERLY
WITH HONOR AND DIGNITY.
QUESTION.
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING.
REGARDING THE MAINTENANCE OF
CEMETERIES HOW OFTEN DOES THE
BUREAU ACTUALLY INSPECT THE
GROUNDS OF CEMETERIES --
ONCE A YEAR OUR BUREAU STAFF
VISIT EACH LICENSE CEMETERY AND
WE ARE A CURRENT IN THAT MANDATE
VERY GOOD DO YOU THINK IT SHOULD
BE MORE OFTEN.
IF THERE IS REASON FOR IT TO BE
MORE OFTEN THERE HAS IN THE PAST
EVEN AS MUCH AS THE PURE
PREVIOUS BURJI MISS MORE WOULD
VISIT --
SPECIFIC CEMETERIES MORE OFTEN
TO ENSURE THOSE MEAN AND
STANDARDS ARE BEING MET VERY
GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA SENATOR
GALGIANI.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR INCLUDING
YOUR BOARD AT THIS HEARING.
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY WE
HAD AN ISSUE WITH A CEMETERY
THAT WAS NOT FINANCIALLY SOLVENT
AND WE HAD TO ADDRESS MANY
ISSUES?
I ENDED UP DOING LEGISLATION AND
DISCOVERED THAT THE STATUTE WAS
QUITE OLD GIVEN THAT NOT VERY
MUCH ATTENTION WAS NORMALLY
GIVEN BY LEGISLATORS --
TO THE CEMETERY BOARD CELL I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT --
SECONDLY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE
CURRENT PROCESS FOR INSURING
THAT -- IS
THAT CEMETERIES ARE SOLVENT.
IS SUFFICIENT OR ARE THERE
CHANGES OR UPDATES THAT WE
SHOULD BE CONSIDERING FOR THAT
PROCESS.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH OUR RECENT
STUDY ON IN DOWN THE CARE FIND
SPECIFIC TO CEMETERIES WITHIN
DOWN THE CARE FUNDS TO ENSURE.
THE LONG RUN MAINTENANCE OF THAT
CEMETERY I BELIEVE THAT --
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THAT REPORT
WHICH AS IT GIVES A
RECOMMENDATION EITHER 10% OF THE
NET PRICE. TO BE REYES FOR THOSE --
FEES FOR ENDEMIC CARE BEANS --
OR THEY GIVE A CERTAIN DOLLAR
AMOUNT DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
INTERNMENT --
I DO RECOMMEND THAT WE LOOK AT
THOSE VERY CLOSELY AND WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S INCREASING
THOSE FEES.
ARE YOU AWARE OF WHETHER THERE
IS ANY PLAN TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THOSE FEES.
THROUGH ANY COMMITTEE OF THE
LEGISLATURE OR OTHERWISE.
I AM I KNOW WHERE --
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING BEING THAT THIS IS
JUST MY SECOND WEEKEND SO I I'LL
BE OUT THERE I THINK THINK
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL WORK WITH
THEM.
ON THIS ISSUE IN PARTICULAR WAS
RAISED IN THE STAFF REPORT AND
WE'LL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON TRYING TO
CALIBRATE THAT IN THE CORRECT
WAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
PANEL MEMBERS WELL LET ME JUST
SAY -- THAT
I APPRECIATE THE SENSITIVITY OF
CENTER TO LAY THAT THAT SHE'S
REYES REGARDED MAINTENANCE THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S AND IT'S
IT'S VERY HARD TO HEAR THAT.
THE PIERCE BROTHERS --
REVIEW AND PROBLEMS THERE AND IT
CERTAINLY GETS ALL OF US
CONCERNED THAT.
THIS ISN'T JUST A ONE OFF THIS
COULD BE HAPPENING IN MANY OTHER
PLACES AND WE WANT TO RESPECT.
THOSE WHO HAVE PASSED AND THAT
MEANS RESPECTING THE PLACE WHERE
THEY ARE VERY DO WE ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE YOUR VIGILANCE THERE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IT'S DONE
CORRECTLY TO SAY THAT THERE IS
SENSITIVITY BY THIS CHAIR AND
MAYBE OTHERS --
ABOUT THAT CIRCUMSTANCE WITH THE
PET CREMATION.
THAT OCCURRED AND WITH A COURAGE
THAT TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD AT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT.
I WAS CONSIDERING --
INTRODUCING LEGISLATION ON THIS
YEAR NOT HELD OFF THE MOMENT.
I'D LOVE TO SEE YOU GUYS COME
TOGETHER IN A SENSIBLE.
PLAN TO MAKE SURE THESE TYPES OF
THINGS DON'T HAPPEN AND AND HOW
WE CAN A MONITOR THAT AND
REGULATED --
WOULD BE SOMETHING I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO YOUR INPUT ON OKAY.
SO WITH THAT I WON IT BY ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC TO COME UP
AND SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS ON THE
SUNSET REVIEW.
BEFORE WE CONCLUDE THIS SITE
THIS PART OF THE HEARING.
WELCOME TO YOU SAY YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD.
SURE MEMBERS JERRY DOES MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CEMETERY AND
MORTUARY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA C. MAC WANTED THANK --
DEAN GARFIELD DIRECTOR FEEL LOW
AND WELCOME ALONG WITH THE
COMMITTEE THE NEW BUREAU CHIEF
FOR REALLY PLEASED TO HAVE.
OF AN APPOINTMENT OF A DIRECTOR
WHO WILL ã PROVIDE LEADERSHIP
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION THAT WE THINK ARE
VITAL -- AND
SO THEREFORE ALSO ENCOURAGED OF
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
MECHANISMS AND LIKE TO JUST
ADDRESS THREE OF THE ISSUES
BRIEFLY THAT BROUGHT UP IN THE
COMMITTEE --
IN THE COMMITTEE BACKGROUND
PAPER STARTING WITH THE INTEL
MAKER FUNDS.
YOU KNOW AND OF PICKING UP ON
THE CENTER GALGIANI A PROPERLY
IT MENTIONED AND THAT IS
PROVIDING FOR THE FUTURE OF
CEMETERIES IN THEIR ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THE MAINTENANCE CARE
THE CEMETERY SPECIALLY AFTER.
THERE'S NO MORE ROOM OF WE
PARTICIPATED AS THE PUBLIC IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE ATOMIC
CARE FUND RECOMMENDATIONS AND
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND SUPPORT THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT REPORT.
SO IF THERE WERE TO BE
LEGISLATION THAT COMES OUT OF
THIS PROCESS THAT WOULD INCREASE
THE MINIMUM OF CONTRIBUTIONS TO
AND DOWN OCCUR FUNDS TO EITHER.
BASICALLY DOUBLE THE MINIMUM
CONTRIBUTION FOR A 10% OF THE
FAIR MARKET VALUE OF THE PRICE
THE FOR FOR THE PRICE.
OF THAT IT APPLAUDED SOLD A WE
WOULD SUPPORT THAT LEGISLATION
THINK IT WOULD HELP PROVIDE FOR
THE FUTURE OF VIABILITY OF
ATOMIC HER FUNDS AND ALSO NOTE
THAT.
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ENACTED
JUST -- TWO
YEARS AGO EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SIX
BY SOME MEMBERS IRWIN ALSO
PROVIDES A UNIT TRUST A
DISTRIBUTION METHOD FOR INTEL
MAKER FUNDS.
OF THAT WILL ALSO HELP FOR THE
FUTURE VIABILITY ODOMETER FUNDS
AND WE KNOW THE PAYROLL --
PREPARING REGULATIONS ON THAT
APART TO ENACTMENT NEXT YEAR.
SECONDLY IN TERMS OF THE
MAINTENANCE STANDARDS YOU KNOW
OUR ASSOCIATION INDUSTRY ALSO
PARTICIPATED IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE MEAT AND STANDARDS AS
REQUIRED BY LAW.
IN THE PUBLIC ABOVE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND SUPPORT THE MEAT AND
STANDARDS AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE MAINTENANCE STANDARDS OF
WE KNOW THAT THE PROPERTY THAT'S
BEEN MENTIONED IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER IS A MEMBER OF OUR
ASSOCIATION.
AND WE'VE CONFERRED WITH THEM
ABOUT THEIR CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
COMPLY WITH THE STANDARDS AS
MANDATED BY THE LAW AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL MAKE
THEIR THE BEST THE GOOD FAITH
EFFORTS.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE THE STEP UP
COMPLIANCE MODEL THAT --
INFORMED FOR SMITH THE BUREAU IN
THE DEPARTMENT AT KERRY
DEPARTMENT WIDE IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT CONSUMER PROTECTION
WE THINK THIS MODEL OF SHOE IS
BEING PURSUED HERE WE SUPPORT
THAT.
THEN FINALLY ON THE PET
CREMATORIUMS AND WE ARE ALSO
SENSITIVE TO THE SITUATION IN
THE CONSUMER THAT IS --
HAD THE ISSUE WITH THE PRESS OF
PET CREMATORIUMS WE WERE JUST
EMPHASIZES DISCUSSIONS BEFORE
THAT YOU THE ENTIRE CEMETERY
FUNERAL BUREAU THE FUNDING OF
THE BUREAU THE FOCUS OF THE
BUREAU OF THE GREAT BODIES OF
LAWS THAT ARE OUT THERE ARE.
FOR THE INTERNET HUMAN REMAINS
AND THAT THE AND THE FEES THAT
ARE PAID BY THE INDUSTRY TO
SUPPORT THE BEER ARE FOR HUMAN
REMAINS.
AND SO WE THINK THE APPROPRIATE
LEAD IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS MIGHT
BE MORE APPROPRIATE LIKE THE VET
MED BOARD MORE THAN THE CEMETERY
BUREAU BUT OF COURSE THEY HAVE A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF
LICENSING THE CREMATORY ISN'T
CREMATORY STANDARDS BUT WE'RE
VERY SENSITIVE TO THIS.
IDEA OF PETS AND HUMANS
EVERYONE'S WELL THERE'S A
DISCUSSION OF HAVING THEM IN THE
SAME CEMETERY AND THERE'S A REAL
SENSIBILITY TO THE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS OF THEIR
EXPECTATIONS.
SO WE REALLY SEE --
A LINE THERE A BIT THAT WE WANT
TO BE IF YOU'RE CAREFUL ABOUT AS
WE IS IN THEIR BLOOD RIGHT VERY
GOOD THANK FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FUNERAL DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
MR CHEAP CALL THIS LAST NIGHT ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND I WAS CAUGHT OFF GUARD BY
JUST HOW BIG.
OF AN INDUSTRY THIS HAS BECOME
IN TERMS OF TAKING CARE OF PETS
AT THIS AT THE END OF LIFE WE
HAD A LITTLE KITTY THE HEADS
SELECT ON MY SON'S BED ALL OF
HIS LIFE AND WHEN HE WE PUT THAT
CáC A VERY SECOND WE PUT HER TO
SLEEP.
THE VETERINARIAN VETERINARY
HOSPITAL OFFERED US THE CHOICE
OF EITHER WE CREMATE THE CAT
INDIVIDUALLY WE CREMATED IN A
GROUP.
AND SO WE CHOSE INDIVIDUALLY AND
THEY GIVE YOU A LITTLE.
YOU KNOW THEY SEND THE ASHES
BACK AND I THOUGHT IT WAS A NICE
THING TO DO WHAT I DIDN'T
REALIZE IS THAT THIS IS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR BUSINESS.
AND WE SHARED WITH MISTER CHIEF.
OF THIS MORNING THE CATALOG. FOR
CREMATORY DEVICES AND THAT FOR
HUMAN BEINGS WAS TWO PAGES. FOR
PETS IT IS FOUR PAGES SO IT IS
SOMETHING WORTH LOOKING AT AND
WORTH TALKING ABOUT.
AND WITH MISTER GAGE MISTER SHE
WOULD BE WILLING TO ENGAGE AT
YOUR CONVENIENCE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALRIGHT
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC.
CLOSE THAT PART OF THE HEARING.
BRING THE MATTER BACK --
I THINK THAT THERE IS A GREATER
ENLIGHTENMENT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR PETS AND
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY THAT.
RECOGNIZES THAT WE ARE
INTERESTED IN PROTECTING THE
CONSUMER.
AND A PART OF THAT IS --
TAKING A LOOK AT THESE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
BEING DONE RIGHT AND AND IF THE
RIGHT SPIRIT.
I WITHOUT ANY FINAL COMMENTS AS
WE CLOSE DOWN THIS PART OF OUR
SUNSET REVIEW.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING DID GREAT ON YOUR FIRST.
ONE AND WE GIVE IT TO YOU
FEEDBACK AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THEIR STAFFS ON THE
ISSUES THAT WE DISCUSSED STARTED
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT TODAY.
THANK YOU THAT'LL TURN THE
MATTER BACK TO CHEER LOW.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS
MOVES US DOWN TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS THE REVIEW OF THE
COURT REPORTERS BORDER OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN WILL HAVE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS --
ISSUES TO BE DIRECT
.
WELCOME WE GET IF WE KEEP UP
WE'LL HAVE OF NO MORE THAN
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR TOTAL
PRESENTATIONS A BIT FEEL FREE TO
JUST GET RIGHT INTO THE ISSUES
AS I KNOW THAT WE ARE VERY WELL
VERSED WITH.
A CORE PORTERS BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA SO PLEASE PEOPLE FEEL
FREE 2% WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU --
GOOD MORNING CO CHAIRS LOW AND
GLAZER AND FELLOW MEMBERS MY
NAME STAVING HURT I AM BOARD
CHAIR AS WELL AS MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF BELMONT --
I'M HERE TODAY WITH ELIZABETH
LIST AND SKI SHE'S THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE SUNSET REVIEW
COMMITTEE AND FELLOW BOARD
MEMBER.
AND YVONNE FENDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
SO I WILL GO STRAIGHT INTO THE
ISSUE.
WHAT IS THE STATUS OF THE
TRANSCRIPT --
REIMBURSEMENT FUND THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER.
ONE FUNDED COMPLETELY FROM COURT
REPORTER LICENSE FEES THE T. R.
F. WAS SET UP TO ASSIST
QUALIFIED INDIGENT LITIGANTS
WITH TRANSCRIPT COSTS.
THE FUN IS TO PROGRAMS THE MAIN
FUND SET UP IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE REQUIRES INDIGENT LITIGANTS
TO HAVE A PRO BONO ATTORNEY
HANDLING THE CASE.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN A TWO YEAR
PILOT PROJECT WAS DEVELOPED TO
ALLOW PROPER LITIGANTS.
LIVING IT'S REPRESENTING
THEMSELVES ACCESS TO THE FUN.
BB CODE EIGHTY THIRTY POINT TWO
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD TO TRANSFER
FUNDS TO THE TRF IN INCREMENTS
OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR A
TOTAL OF THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ANNUALLY.
DURING THE BOARDS LAST SUNSET
REVIEW THE CAPITA PRO PER
PROGRAM WHICH RATES FROM.
THIRTY THOUSAND TO SEVENTY FIVE
THIS BECAME EFFECTIVE JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THE WAR WAS
ABLE TO PROCESS TWICE THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS AS IN PRIOR YEARS.
THE PRO BONO PROGRAM RECEIVES
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
FROM THE TOTAL AMOUNT
TRANSFERRED.
ANOTHER CHANGE AS A RESULT OF
THE LATEST --
SUNSET REVIEW WAS THE EXCLUSION
STATIUS LITIGANTS FROM THE T. R.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS OF THAT
CHANGE THIRTY SIX APPLICATIONS
WERE RETURNED ALLOWING
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TO BE DISTRIBUTED TO
TWENTY FIVE NON VEXATIOUS
CLAIMANTS.
BB CODE EIGHTY THIRTY POINT TO A
PROVIDES THAT A TRANSFER THAT TO
THE TRF IN EXCESS OF THE FUND
BALANCE ESTABLISHED AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH FISCAL YEAR.
SHALL NOT BE MADE IF THE BOARD --
BY THE BOARD IF THE TRANSFER
WILL RESULT IN THE REDUCTION OF
THE BALANCE OF THE COURT PORTER
SPINE. TO AN AMOUNT LESS THAN
SIX MONTHS OPERATING BUDGET.
DESPITE TIGHTENING OUR BELTS
WITH YOUR MEETINGS PURSUING A
FEW INCREASING PACE OF RETIRING
LICENSEES.
KEEPING A SMALL BUT MIGHTY STAFF
WITH RISING LABOR COSTS THE
BOARD WAS UNABLE TO TRANSFER
FUNDS TO THE TRF.
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE BOARD WAS ABLE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED THROUGH
JULY SIXTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH
THE REMAINING FUNDS --
AND THE TIARA.
AND AT THE TIME THE T. R.
AFFLECK FUNDS THE BOARDS FREE
INCREASED REGULATION PACKAGE WAS
STILL UNDER DEPARTMENT --
AND AGENCY REVIEW AND HAD NOT
BEEN SUBMITTED TO OIL FOR REVIEW.
THEREFORE WAS DEEMED PRUDENT --
TO SEND THURMOND ON HOW TO RESET
MET WHEN THE FUND RE OPENED.
THE LICENSE FEE INCREASE PORTION
OTHER REGULATIONS PACKAGE WAS
APPROVED AND BECAME EFFECTIVE
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THE LATEST
REVENUE AND EXPENDITURE
PROJECTIONS INDICATE THAT A
TRANSFER CAN BE MADE AND JULY.
TWENTY TWENTY THE PLAN IS TO
TRANSFER A HUNDRED THOUSAND AS
SOON AS A BOARD IS ABLE TO DO SO
WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE
REQUIRED SIX MONTHS OPERATING
EXPENSE RESERVES.
OUR ELIZABETH ASCENDS GUILTY
SPEAKING TO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO SHOULD CERTIFIED SHORTHAND
REPORTER IS BE ALLOWED TO USE
VOICE WRITING SYSTEMS.
ADDED TO JULY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MEETING THE BOARD WAS
ABLE TO VIEW A DEMONSTRATION OF
VOICE WRITING REAL TIME
TECHNOLOGY.
IT BECAME APPARENT TO THE BOARD
THE VOICE WRITING AND STONE A
WRITING OR THE SAME SKILL BUT
USING DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES TO
CAPTURE THEIR SHORT AND WITH
STAND ARE WRITING WORDS ARE
TAKEN DOWN ENOUGH PHONE ADDICT.
BASED SHORTHAND USING SYMBOLS
BASED ON LETTERS OF THE ALPHABET.
THE STENO WRITER USES A COMPUTER
PROGRAM TO BUILD A DICTIONARY
THAT RECOGNIZES COMBINATIONS OF
LETTERS AND TRANSLATED INTO
ENGLISH.
VOICE WRITERS USE VOICE
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE ENOUGH.
SIMILAR FASHION THEY PROGRAM THE
SOFTWARE TO TRANSLATE THEIR
SPOKEN SHORTHAND INTO ENGLISH
BECAUSE OF THE SIMILARITY.
VOICE WRITERS WILL BE ABLE TO
TAKE THE EXACT SAME EXAMINATION
IN ORDER TO BECOME CERTIFIED.
THE BOARD ORIGINALLY PROPOSED
TESTING CURRENT LICENSEES WHO
WANT TO SWITCH FROM STUNT ALL
WRITING. TO VOICE WRITING BUT
DISCOVERED IT DOES NOT HAVE A
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO DO SO.
LEGISLATIVE STAFF RECOMMENDS
DEMONSTRATING COMPETENCY IN
EITHER OR BOTH METHODS.
GRANDFATHERING IN ALL CURRENT
LICENSEES AS STENO WRITER'S A
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE WILL BE
NEEDED TO AFFIRM THAT CURRENT
CERTIFICATE HOLDERS WILL HAVE TO
RETEST THE SKILLS PORTION.
OF THE EXAM IF THEY WISH TO
CHANGE REPORTING METHODOLOGIES%
THE BOARD IS HAPPY TO PLACE THE
LEGISLATIVE.
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
NECK DURATION.
I WILL ALSO BE SPEAKING TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
THREE SHOULD THE BOARD REQUIRE
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTERS TO
MEET NEW CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS.
THE CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT OF THIRTY HOURS OVER
THREE OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD.
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO THE
REQUIREMENTS TO MAINTAIN
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION IS THE
BOARD'S RECOMMENDATION.
ADDITIONALLY TON OF THOSE HOURS
SHOULD BE ETHICS COURSES.
THE BOARD SUGGEST A MANDATE FROM
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRING PROOF
OF COMPLETION TO BE SENT TO THE
BOARD AS A CONDITION OF LICENSE
RENEWAL.
THE BOARD WILL TRACK TO
CONTINUING EDUCATION WITH
EXISTING STUFF.
BECAUSE THERE IS ALREADY A
REQUIREMENT FOR CONTINUING
EDUCATION FOR NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION AS WELL AS FOR
OFFICIAL COURT REPORTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE MANY COMPANIES
PROVIDING CLASSES OFFERED FOR
CONTINUING EDUCATION CREDIT.
INCLUDING ONLINE SEMINARS.
IT COSTS FOR CONCERNING
EDUCATION COURSES VERY STRONG
CONFERENCE SEMINAR REGISTRATION
FOR STATE AND OR NATIONALLY
EVENTS TO FREE TASK GIVEN ON
MATERIAL.
PROVIDED BY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION.
IN ADDITION TO ALLOWING FOR
DISCRETIONARY HARDSHIP WAIVER
THE BOARD WOULD WORK WITH SOLID.
WHICH IS D. C. A.'S TRAINING
UNIT TO DEVELOP TESTING
MATERIALS ON BOARD PUBLICATIONS
SAYS THAT SUCH AS THEIR
NEWSLETTER OR WEBSITE.
THE BORED KIDS THAT'S WEBSITE
UPDATED WITH ALL CHANGES TO LAWS
AND REGULATIONS.
AS WELL AS PUBLISHING A
NEWSLETTER TWICE A YEAR WITH
SUCH CHANGES.
THE BOARD ALSO DISTRIBUTES NEW
LAW LAWS AND REGULATION CHANGES
BY ITS EMAIL SUBSCRIPTION LIST.
ALL OF THESE ALTERNATE METHODS
OF EDUCATION ARE VOLUNTARY AND
ALREADY IN PLACE SUGGESTING THE
MANDATORY THING COMPONENT BUT
THE NECESSARY TO ENSURE ALL
LICENSEES ARE UP TO DATE.
I WILL SPEAK TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX
IS THE BOARD ABLE TO ENFORCE --
COURT REPORTING STATUTES AGAINST
FOREIGN COURT REPORTING
CORPORATIONS.
THE BOARD HAS HAD A LONG JOURNEY --
IN ITS QUEST TO ENSURE ALL
COMPANIES OFFERING COURT
REPORTING SERVICES OBEY THE SAME
LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
GOVERNING COURT REPORTING.
STARTING WITH CONVENING A TASK
FORCE TO EXPLORE THESE ISSUES
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE THE BOARD
SUPPORTED AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE
WHICH ULTIMATELY FELL PASSAGE.
HOWEVER IN TWENTY TEN THE BOARD
RECEIVED A COMPLAINT AGAINST A
U. S. LEGAL FOR VIOLATION OF
GIFT GIVING PROVISIONS.
AFTER AN INVESTIGATION A
CITATION OF FINE WAS ISSUED BUT
U. S. LEGAL DENIED THE BOARD'S
JURISDICTION.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE BOARD
BROUGHT SUIT AGAINST YOU AS
COURT IN THAT MATTER FOUND THAT
ALTHOUGH U. S. LEGAL WAS
RENDERING COURT REPORTING
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WAS INDEED IN VIOLATION OF
THE GIFT GIVING REGULATIONS --
WHICH I WOULD SAY IS CREATED TO
PROTECT CONSUMER EXPLICIT OR
EXPRESS AUTHORITY STATUTES.
AUTHORIZING THE BOARD TO IMPOSE
CITATIONS ARE FINES AGAINST A
FOREIGN CORPORATION.
THE HEART OF THIS PROBLEM IS
WITH THE BOARD'S JURISDICTION
OVER THESE NON LICENSEE OWNED
OUT OF STATE CORPORATIONS.
CORPORATION CO THIRTEEN FOR TEN
A REQUIRES PROFESSIONAL
CORPORATIONS DEFINED AS THOSE.
THAT PROVIDE SERVICES FOR WHICH
A LICENSE IS REQUIRED BE SUBJECT
TO THE SAME RULES AND
REGULATIONS AS LICENSEES.
SO WELL BY OF BOTH THE
CORPORATION'S CODE AND THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE --
CLEAR THAT LICENSEES AND
PROFESSIONAL CORPORATIONS MUST
BE HELD TO ALL THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS APPLICABLE TO THE
PRACTICE OF COURT REPORTING.
THE CORPORATIONS IN QUESTION
CLAIMED THAT THEY ARE MERELY
ARRANGING FOR COURT REPORTING
SERVICES AND ARE NOT PROVIDING
THEM.
THEREFORE THEY ARE EXEMPT FROM
ANY LAWS APPLICABLE TO LICENSEES.
THIS WOULD MEAN PURSUING AN
OBJECTION AGAINST EACH
CORPORATION INDIVIDUALLY AND THE
COURT WOULD NEED TO DETERMINE ON
A CASE BY CASE BASIS AND THAT
CORPORATION WE'RE PROVIDING
COURT REPORTING SERVICES.
CLEARLY A DECISION OF THIS
FINANCIAL MAGNITUDE WE NEED TO
BE ANALYZED CAREFULLY AND
CONJUNCTION WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
THE BOARD WITH THE HELP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA PURSUED
FIRM REGISTRATION AS A SOLUTION
TO THIS PROBLEM AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN THE FORM OF AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY THE BILL WAS
VETOED BY THEN GOVERNOR BROWN
AND A NEW APPROACH WAS TAKEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHTY
FOUR AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
CHIPPED AWAY AT THIS PROBLEM
WITH TARGETING THE MOST
EGREGIOUS COMPLAINTS RELATING TO
THE INTEGRITY OF THE TRANSCRIPT.
THIS SUCCESSFUL SIGNING INTO LAW
OF AB --
TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR BY KALRA
EFFECTIVELY --
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR THE
BOARD TWO ONE FOUR SPECIFIC
STATUTES.
AS OUTLAWED OUTLINED IN THE NEW
LAW.
SPECIFICALLY NO ONE INCLUDING
NON LICENSEE OWNED FIRMS MAY
CHARGE FOR TRANSCRIPT THAT IS
FORMATTED IN VIOLATION OF THE
MINIMUM TRANSCRIPT FORMAT
STANDARDS WHICH ARE DEFINED IN
REGULATION.
NORMA THEY CHARGE FEES FOR COURT
TRANSCRIPTS THAT ARE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH FEES SET OUT IN
THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
ADDITIONALLY ALL TRANSCRIPTS
MUST BE MADE AVAILABLE TO ALL
PARTIES AT THE SAME TIME AND ALL
PARTIES MUST BE NOTIFIED OF A
REQUEST FOR PREPARATION OF ALL
OR ANY PORTION OF TRANSCRIPT.
INCLUDING AT CERTS AND EXPEDITES.
WHICH IS EQUITY.
WHILE THE RIP REMEDY OF OF FOR
THESE VIOLATIONS OF CIVIL
LITIGATION RATHER THAN IT AND
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION DIRECTLY
FROM THE BOARD.
IT IS NOW CLEAR THAT THESE LAWS
AND REGULATIONS DO APPLY TO THE
OUT OF STATE CORPORATIONS AND
THERE'S A REMEDY FOR VIOLATION.
IT IS SPEND US LEGALS ASSERTION
THAT THE SCOPE OF COURT
REPORTING IS LIMITED TO BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS CODE EIGHT ZERO ONE
SEVEN THE MAKING OF SYMBOLS ON A
MACHINE.
THE REST OF THAT CODE INCLUDES
AND THE TRANSCRIPTION THEY'RE
OFF MAKING IT CLEAR THAT THE
TRANSCRIPT IS IN THE CENTRAL
PART OF COURT REPORTING DUTIES.
NOT ONLY SUPERIOR COURT AND
COURT REPORTERS BOARD VERSUS US
LEGAL BUT ALSO THE APPELLATE
COURT AND MOOSE VERSUS US LEGAL
FOUND.
THAT US LEGAL IS OFFERING COURT
REPORTING SERVICES.
WELL THIS WOULD BE SUPPORT FOR
AN ARGUMENT OF THE BOARD'S
JURISDICTION UNDER MOSCONI
KNOCKS IT SHOULD BE POINTED OUT
THAT THE MOOSE DECISION ISN'T ON
PUBLISHED DECISION.
AND MAY NOT BE RELIED UPON BY
THE COURT.
WE ARE INVESTED IN FIGURING THIS
OUT.
THE BOARD HAS RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS FROM COURT REPORTERS
WHO ALLEGE THE BUSINESS
PRACTICES OF THE FOREIGN
CORPORATIONS ARE PUTTING THEM
OUT OF BUSINESS.
EACH COMPLAINT IS INVESTIGATED
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
BUT IF THE BOARD WERE TO PURSUE
SOME TYPE OF IN JUNCTION IT
SEEMS TWO THINGS MAY HAPPEN.
FIRSTTHE COURT HEARING THE CASE
COULD NARROWLY INTERPRET THE
DEFINITION OF COURT REPORTING
SET OUT AND BE P..
EIGHTY SEVEN TEN IN WHICH CASE
THE FOREIGN CORPORATIONS ARE NOT
PROVIDING SERVICES AND THERE'S
NO BASIS UPON WHICH TO REQUIRE
LICENSING.
SHOULD THE COURT FIND THAT THEY
ARE PROVIDING COURT REPORTING
SERVICES THE BOARD WOULD THEN
HAVE JURISDICTION ARE UNDER
MOSCONI KNOCKS.
CERTAINLY NO REAL GAIN TO
CONSUMERS COMES FROM EITHER
RESULTS.
THE BOARD FILL SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB.
TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR AND WILL
CLOSELY MONITOR ON ANY AND ALL
VIOLATIONS.
THE BOARD EMBRACES ITS CONSUMER
PROTECTION MISSION AND HAS
WORKED HARD TO PARLAY SCARCE AND
LIMITED RESOURCES.
INTO THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT OPERATION POSSIBLE.
THE BOARD CONCURS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFFS ASSERTION
THAT THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
WELFARE OF THE PUBLIC ARE BETTER
PROTECTED BY WELL REGULATED
COURT REPORTING PROFESSION.
THE BOARD IS COMMITTED TO THE
MISSION IS GIVEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE SIXTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
AND LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANY CONCERNS
MAY FIND ARISING OUT OF THIS
REVIEW.
WE'RE OPEN FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME FOR MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THIS TIME WITH ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK.
AT THIS TIME PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
AND NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
WISH TO PROVIDE IT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS THE MORNING.
MY NAME IS KELLY SHANE LINE.
I AM A FREELANCE COURT REPORTER
AND VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
DEPOSITION REPORTERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE LARGEST INFERS ORGANIZATION
IN THE NATION DEVOTED SOLELY TO
FREELANCE COR PORTERS AND
FREELANCE OWN SMALL BUSINESSES.
MEMBERS WE SUPPORT THE EXTENSION
OF THE BOARD AND THANK THE BOARD
FOR ITS HARD WORK.
HOWEVER THE LAWS THAT PROTECT MY
PROFESSIONAL ETHICS FROM BEING
COMPROMISED BY A CORPORATION'S
DUTY TO MAXIMIZE SHAREHOLDER
VALUE.
ARE ESSENTIALLY THE SAME AS THE
LAWS THAT PROTECT LAWYERS CPA'S
AND DOCTORS AND EVERY OTHER
PROFESSION UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
JESSE THE AMAZON OR A VENTURE
CAPITAL FUND CANNOT LEGALLY OWN
A CORPORATION THAT PROVIDES FOR
LEGAL SERVICES FROM LAWYERS ARE
MEDICAL SERVICES FROM DOCTORS.
THE LAW IS CLEAR THAT
CORPORATIONS NOT OWNED BY
LICENSEES CANNOT RENDER MY
SERVICES EITHER.
BUT THEY ARE EVERYWHERE DOING IT
ALL THE TIME.
OUT IN THE OPEN FROM STATES FAR
AWAY ILLEGALLY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT IS HARMING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
THE RESULT CORPORATIONS NOT
LICENSEES ARE UNLAWFULLY
COMPETING AGAINST AND DRIVING
OUT OF BUSINESS LICENSEE OWNED
FIRMS.
OWNED BY OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT
OBEY THE LAWS YOU RIGHT OR RISK
LOSING THEIR LICENSE.
THE CORPORATIONS HIGHER SLICK
COMMISSION SALES PEOPLE WHO
OFFER ILLEGAL KICKBACKS THAT IF
I OFFERED WOULD GET MY LICENSE
REVOKED.
AND MOST RECENTLY THEY'RE
PUSHING SUBPAR DIGITAL RECORDING
THAT IS UNRELIABLE AND
INADMISSIBLE IN COURT WHEREAS
WHAT I DO IS PRODUCE THE
OFFICIAL RECORD.
MEMBERS THIS IS AN EGREGIOUS
MISS REPRESENTATION AND
RESTAURANT.
IN CONCLUSION PLEASE HELP US AND
PLEASE REMEMBER JUST HAVING
CORPORATIONS REGISTER A PIECE OF
PAPER IS NOT ENOUGH.
THERE WILL NEVER EVER BE A FAIR
AND EQUAL INCENTIVE TO OBEY THE
LAWS YOU RIGHT BETWEEN LICENSEE
OWNED FIRMS AND A CORPORATION
UNLESS THERE IS A REAL LIFE
PERSON IN THE CORPORATION.
LIKE ME WHO COULD LOSE THEIR
LICENSE AND LIVELIHOOD JUST LIKE
I COULD IF I VIOLATE THE LAW.
THAT IS THE WAY LITERALLY EVERY
SINGLE OTHER PROFESSION YOU
OVERSEE DOES IT MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY WHY SHOULD IT BE
ANY DIFFERENT FOR ME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
GOOD MORNING I'M SELLING A
COUPLE AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET.
ON A SPEAK VERY BRIEFLY ON
ISSUES ONE AND TWO SO MY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS ROUGHLY
ONE HUNDRED LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MANY IN YOUR
AREA SO YOU KNOW THEM --
AND THEY ACTUALLY SERVE OVER
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS EVERY YEAR
PROVIDING FREE LEGAL SERVICES ON
ISSUES RANGING FROM --
IMMIGRATION ISSUES TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DISPUTES TO HELPING
PEOPLE MAINTAIN THEIR HOUSING --
AND WE HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED
EFFORTS IN THE PAST TO PROTECT
AND EXPAND THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUND IT'S ISSUE.
ONE A WRITTEN A WRITTEN RECORD
OF COURT PROCEEDINGS IS THIS IS
STRENGTHENED BY THE RECENT THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HOLDING
AND JAMESON BE DESTA.
THE COURT HELD THAT A TRIAL
COURT COULD NOT TONIGHT'S
INDIGENT LITIGANTS ACCESS TO
COURT REPORTER.
AND THE TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT
FUND IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
SOURCE OF FUNDING THE LAST TIME
WE WERE IN THIS BUILDING TO
DISCUSS THE SUNSET.
ON OVER DOESN'T LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATION SUBMITTED LETTERS
TO SUPPORT THE FUND AND
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SHARED WITH
ME THAT THEY HAVE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN UNREIMBURSED EXPENSES
WHILE THE PHONE IS ON HOLD.
I'M SOME HAVE OVER TO YOUR
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND UP TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
UNREIMBURSED EXPENSES.
I'M GONNA LEGALLY PROGRAM DOES
NOT HAVE TO SPEND IT SCARCE
RESOURCES ON EXPENSIVE COURT
TRANSCRIPTS IT FREES UP THOSE
FUNDS TO SERVE PEOPLE IN NEED SO
WE ARE.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE THE SUNSET
EXTEND THE SUNSETFOR THAT
REASON THE BRIEFLY ON ISSUE.
TOO I THINK IT'S COMMON SENSE TO
ADAPT TO NEW TECHNOLOGY IS
ESPECIALLY THE CASE OF ALLOWING
THE VOICE.
TRANSCRIPT BECAUSE THAT EXPANDS
ACCESS TO JUSTICE WITH A
SHORTAGE OF COURT REPORTERS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE THIS
ACTUALLY WOULD EXPAND THE BODY
PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
WRITTEN RECORD.
A VERBATIM RECORD OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE COURT WHICH IS
WHAT YOU NEED TO APPEAL A LOWER
COURT HOLDING.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ACT AS A SUPPORT
CENTER FOR MANY OF THE DIFFERENT
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS AND
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS.
WITH MS COPELAND --
WE'VE A LONG SUPPORTED --
THE THAT THE EXTENSION OF THE
SUNSET AND CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CO CHAIRS MEMBERS
KNOW AT BOTTOM ALL WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE LAW
OFFICES A CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE INCORPORATED IS A
STATE WIDE LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAM PROVIDING VITAL.
NEEDED LEGAL SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS IMMIGRANTS AND
FARMWORKERS THROUGHOUT THE RURAL
COUNTIES FROM EL CENTRO AND THE
SOUTH UP TO YUBA CITY.
<c.magenta>ARYSVILLE IN SANTA ROSA AND THE</c>
NORTH HE IS A MODESTLY FUNDED
LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAM.
AND YET THEY ARE SERVING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN NEED OF
LOW INCOME SERVICES.
IN THESE --
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WITHOUT THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUND CRLA WILL BE
DISADVANTAGED FROM PROVIDING
QUALITY LEGAL SERVICES TO ITS
CLIENTS.
THESE CLIENTS FARMWORKERS
IMMIGRANTS POOR PEOPLE.
NEED THE SERVICES SO THEY CAN
GET EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
CURRENTLY FAIRLY INCORPORATED
HAS ABOUT ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IN UNMET NEED.
THROUGH NOT GETTING THESE FUNDS
REIMBURSED AT THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUND.
SO WE SUPPORT EXTENDING THE
SUNSET IN THIS MODEST INCREASE
THE FINES SO THAT'S FAIRLY IN
CAN PROVIDE THESE.
MUCH NEEDED SERVICES TO ITS ITS
CLIENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNATIONAL FEDERAL
FEDERATION OF PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL ENGINEERS --
THIS IS A UNION THAT REPRESENTS
COURT REPORTERS --
IN SAN FRANCISCO EMPLOYED BY THE
COURT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EXTENDING THE SUNSET OF THE WE
DO WANT TO RAISE ONE CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE ON THE VOICE
WRITING ISSUE --
WE WE HAVE A CONCERN THAT THAT
THAT WAS REYES TODAY --
BY THE BOARD ITSELF ABOUT
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO GO
FORWARD WE BELIEVE THAT THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY NEEDS TO BE
GRANTED AND WE NEED TO HAVE A
SLOWER PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN
DEVELOP THE RIGHT PROGRAM THAT
PROTECTS CONSUMERS.
THE WAY IT'S MOVING FORWARD
RIGHT NOW.
WE THINK HAS SOME ISSUES WITH IT
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE BOARD.
THE COMMITTEE AND DEPARTMENT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBER MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RACHEL BAR KIßM I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
KNOWN AS THE CRA.
AS HE'S VERY SUPPORTS THE
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET FOR THIS
YEAR BE HOWEVER THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AS YOU HAVE DISCUSSED
TODAY.
HE'S VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTS%
MANDATING IS CONTINUING
EDUCATION WE KNOW FIRST HAND
THAT LICENSEES ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN ENSURING THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF PROFESSIONAL
COMPETENCE.
AND WE HOLD REGULAR CONTINUING
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STATE FOR AT CALIFORNIA'S
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTERS.
AS HE ALSO BELIEVES IT IS TIME
TO FORMALLY LICENSE CART CAPTION
OURS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS YEAR BE AS LONG TERM PLAN
INCLUDES THIS ISSUE BUT HAS NOT
YET HAPPENED.
CART CAPTION OR SERVE AS
CRITICAL BRIDGES BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA'S DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING COMMUNITY AND COURT
PROCEEDINGS EDUCATIONAL AND
OTHER SERVICES.
LICENSE COURT REPORTERS OFTEN
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES AND SEIZE
YOUR A AS AN ASSOCIATION
PROVIDES TRAINING AND TESTING
BUT THE CRB DOES NOT.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN KLAY ENVOYS WRITERS
CAESAR ASKS THAT YOU MOVED AS
SWIFTLY FOR COURT FOR CART
CAPTION EARNS.
I WE ALSO AGREE WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO MAKE NECESSARY
STATUTORY CHANGES TO INCORPORATE
VOICE WRITERS AND THE NEED FOR A
SPECIALIZED TEST BEFORE A
LICENSEE IS PERMITTED TO UTILIZE
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THE CRB NEEDS TO
CLARIFY THIS REQUIREMENT FOR
CURRENT LICENSEES TO ENSURE THAT
SOMEONE CAN OPERATE AS A VOICE
WRITER ONLY AFTER SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING A SPECIFIC SKILLS
TEST THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BUT YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE HERNANDEZ
ALSO BEHALF OF CCRI --
JUST A COUPLE THINGS ON THE
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT FUND --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CORPORATE SOCIO
ASIANS VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF OF
AND WE BELIEVE NOT ONLY THAT THE
FUNDING SHOULD BE RESTORED.
BUT THE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR STATUTORY LEVEL SHOULD BE
INCREASED TO FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND IS REALLY --
DISAPPOINTING AND TROUBLESOME
THAT WE HAVE SO MANY LOW INCOME
LITIGANTS IN CALIFORNIA HER
UNABLE TO GET ACCESS TO
TRANSCRIPTS OR CAN AFFORD
TRANSCRIPTS.
ON OVER THE LAST YEAR TO THEY'VE
BEEN UNABLE TO DO THAT WE MADE
EFFORTS LAST YEAR TO GET SOME
MONEY IN THE BUDGET. TO
SUPPLEMENT --
THE TERROR HALF OF THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN --
UNFORTUNATELY NOW THAT THE ON
ALL LICENSEES --
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
SHOULD BE PUTTING MONEY INTO THE
T. R. HALF PERIOD BEFORE ANY
EXPANSION ON ANYTHING ELSE OTHER
SERVICES.
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN NEEDS TO
HAPPEN AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND LOOK AT ANY OTHER WAY TO PUT
TO PUT SOME FUNDING INTO THE TRF --
I THINK AS SOMEONE SAID EARLIER
THE JAMISON DECISION UNDERSCORES
THE IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING ALL
THE RESOURCES TO LOW INCOME THAT
AGAINST CALIFORNIA --
AND SO THIS IS QUITE VERY VERY
CRITICAL NEED TO BE DONE --
AS FAR AS THE OUT OF STATE OF
FIRMS ARE OPERATING WE CONCUR
WITH THE BOARD'S COMMENTS --
THAT YOU SOME GOOD STEPS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN WE WERE WITH THE
BOARD ON THE CALIBER BILLS WE
SPONSOR OWN BILLS AS WELL.
AND ANYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO FURTHER STRENGTHEN WE
WANT TO BE A PART OF IT WE NEED
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION SO
ANYTHING MORE THAN NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
WE WILL BE THERE --
BUT OVERALL WE DO SUPPORT THIS
YEAR BE SUNSET EXTENSION AS LONG
AS THESE ISSUES ARE BEING
ADDRESSED AS WHERE INDICATED
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE CAST OF
THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION WE REPRESENT
COURT REPORTERS AND THIRTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND I'M ETERNALLY ONE
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY.
MISTER HERNANDEZ --
C. C. RATE AND MISTER GLASSMAN.
I JUST WANNA MAKE ONE COMMENT --
REGARDING RECEIVE SHORTAGE OF
COURT REPORTERS --
I THINK THAT THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY --
SIX THOUSAND LICENSE COURT
REPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
SOMEONE THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF I
THINK WHAT --
FOURTEEN HUNDRED JUDGES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING
IN SEEING IN EACH TRIAL COURT
THAT HAS HAD OPENINGS FOR COURT
REPORTERS THERE'S A MULTITUDE OF
APPLICANTS FOR EXAMPLE.
I READ IN THE REPORT JUST THIS
MORNING FOR ONE OPEN POSITION IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SIXTY NINE
APPLICANTS APPLIED FOR THAT JOB
COURTS ARE HIRING COURT
REPORTERS --
SO WE DON'T THINK THAT THERE IS
A SHORTAGE NOW THERE IS A
PERCEPTION OF A SHORTAGE BECAUSE
SOME COUNTIES HAVE A HARD TIME
RECRUITING COURT REPORTERS.
BECAUSE THE WAGES ARE LOW THE
COMMUTES FAR OTHER THINGS LIKE
THAT BUT GENERAL I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT WE SUPPORT THE
EXTENSION OF THE CENTER FOR THE
C. R. PORT THANK YOU.
THIS RETURN MEMBERS UP MIKE
BILLOWED ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF COURT REPORTING
ENTITIES --
YOU KNOW FIRST SUCH SHOULD
DISCRETE AREA OF COMMERCE COURT
REPORTING RAISES AN AMAZING
ARRAY OF ISSUES.
THAT ARE A CHALLENGE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN A TECHNOLOGY IS
ONE OF THEM AND YOU'VE HEARD.
IN A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT VIEWS OF
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE A SHORTAGE --
WELL YOU YOU MAY TALK ABOUT
OFFICIAL REPORTERS IN COURTS BUT
WE'RE TOLD THERE'S SOMETHING OF
A SHORTAGE IN THE DEPOSITION
WORLD IN THE FREELANCERS --
YOU HAVE A VERY VERY LOW PASS
RATE FOR PEOPLE ATTEMPTING TO
BECOME COURT REPORTERS AND THAT
OUGHT TO BE LOOKED AT THE
QUESTION OF OUT OF STATEI
REPRESENT AS MS HURT NOTED --
THE MOOSE DECISION WHICH IS ON
APPEAL -- IS
A NON PUBLISHED CASE AND WE WILL
PLEDGE TO WORK WITH THE BOARD
AND WITH THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
TO ARRIVE AT A SATISFACTORY
OUTCOME.
THAT CAN NOT EXACERBATE THE
SHORTAGE CONTINUE TO ALLOW
LAWYERS TO HIRE A FREELANCE
COURT REPORTERS TO HANDLE
DEPOSITIONS IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE PUBLIC --
AND WE'VE TALKED TO YOUR STAFF
ABOUT IT WE THINK THERE'S A PATH
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING
THAT PATH TOGETHER THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAMERON
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND WE DO SUPPORT
THE EXTENSION AS WELL AND WOULD
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS
WITH -- THAT
OF MR GASSMAN MISTER HERNANDEZ
IN MISS CASTRO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME --
SEEING NONE OF ANY OF FINAL
REMARKS FROM [inaudible]
OUR REPORT.
I THINK WE'VE SET I BET THIS.
MORNING --
BACKGROUND PAPERS VERY AND
CONCLUSIVE THAN YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I KNOW AMERICA
THAT I SAW YOU TAKING COPIOUS
NOTES SAYS THAT THE SPEAKERS
WERE THERE TOO SO.
I KNOW THAT WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE DIALOGUE
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE ORDER OF OUR BEING
HERE WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN OF THE
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER SIX WHICH IS
THE A REVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS --
WE HAVE OUR DIRECTOR OF DCA HERE
IN EUROPE.
AND IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
DIRECTOR CALL FEEL OPPRESSED YOU
CAN JUST GET INTO SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AS YOU SEE FIT --
THE CALL COX'S ARE GONNA BE --
CONVENING HERE SH VERY SHORTLY --
SO BE AS BRIEF AS WE SHOULD BE
ISSUES.
ABSOLUTELY --
SENSITIVE OF OFFICE THE NEED FOR
MEMBERS TO BE CAUCUS AND I'LL
JUMP RIGHT INTO THE ISSUE.
FIRST THE COMMITTEE HAS ASKED
THE CA TO COMMENT ON ITS EFFORTS
RELATED TO DYNAMICS THE DYNAMICS
DECISION ESTABLISHING NEW TEST
FOR DETERMINING.
WHETHER A WORKER.
IS AN EMPLOYEE OR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR FOR PURPOSES OF
CALIFORNIA WAGE ORDERS.
WE DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT THE
DYNAMICS DECISION WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT
PROFESSIONAL LICENSEES SUCH AS
DOCTORS DENTISTS AND OF TOM
TRYST.
BUT IT COULD IMPACT OTHER
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSEES UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT.
BECAUSE TIME EXCISION WITH
GENERAL EFECTO CERTAIN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING LICENSEES
STRUCTURES AND OR AN ORGANIZER
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIPS.
RATHER THAN HOW THE BOARDS
REGULATE THE LICENSEES MOST
AFFECTED BORE MOST AFFECTED
BOARDS ARE TAKING A WAIT AND SEE
APPROACH.
DISCOVER THE DYNAMIC DIED
DYNAMICS DECISION IS STILL BEING
REFINED BY THE COURTS AND THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE APPROPRIATE
GLACIER LABOR AGENCIES. TO
DETERMINE THE APPLICATION OF THE
DECISION AND THE POSSIBLE IMPACT
OF LICENSEES UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
NATIONS HAS A MORE DIRECT ROLE
IN INTERPRETING AND PROVIDING
GUIDANCE ON THESE BUSINESS AND
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIPS.
HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT HAS
RESPONDED TO QUESTIONS FROM
BOARDS ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
ON THE MEANING AND POTENTIAL
IMPACTS OF THE DECISION.
THE DEPARTMENT CONFERRED WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE ON
THE IMPACTS OF THE DECISION TO
THE CONTRACTOR STATE LICENSING
BOARD.
THEY JUST THE DECISION WAS ALSO
DISCUSSED EXTENSIVELY BY THE
BORDER BARBERINI COSMETOLOGY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDED
GUIDANCE TO THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY REGARDING POTENTIAL
IMPACTS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS CLOSELY
TRACKING LEGISLATION THIS YEAR
ON THE ISSUE AND RIVER AND WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE TO
PROGRAMS HAS NEED.
THE SECOND ISSUE LIKE TO ADDRESS
FOCUS THAT FOCUSES ON PUBLIC
ACCESS TO MEETINGS FOR OUR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROUD OF THE
COLLABORATION WITH OUR PROGRAMS
TO PROVIDE HUNDREDS OF OPEN
MEETINGS EACH YEAR.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE OUR
PROGRAMS HELP THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX MEETINGS AND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MEETINGS WERE
AVAILABLE VIA WEBCAST.
THESE MEETINGS WERE HELD UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
VARIOUS REGIONS INCLUDING THE
BAY AREA.
SACRAMENTO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO.
IN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE ACCESS
SOME PRO MEETINGS ON ON THE
WEEKEND SUCH AS THE DENTAL
HYGIENE.
DENTAL HYGIENE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE BOARD OF
BARBARY IN COSMETOLOGY.
DO YOU SEE A MEETING WEBCASTS
ARE AVAILABLE ON A SINGLE SITE.
ALONG WITH A LINK TO THE BOARD
OF BOARD OR BUREAU AND VICE WE
COMMITTEES AGENDA.
THESE WEBCASTS ARE ALSO PROMOTED
ON DO YOU SEE A SOCIAL MEDIA
PAGES AND THE WEB CASTS ARE
ARCHIVED ON PCA'S YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
WELL WE SEEK TO BROADCAST AS
MANY MEETINGS AS POSSIBLE DUE TO
THE HIGH VOLUME OF MEETINGS FROM
OUR DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE ABLE TO DO SO FOR EVERY
MEAL EASY FOR EVERY MEETING AS
IT WOULD PREVENT IT WOULD
PRESENT A RESOURCE AND BUDGETARY
CHALLENGE FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND
ITS PROGRAMS.
DC CONTINUES TO BE OPEN TO
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING EXPANDING
WHAT CASTING OR OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES TO ALLOW GREATER
PUBLIC ASK ACCESS. TO BOARD
MEETS.
MY GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS AND INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE IN PERSON VIA WEBCAST
BY TELECONFERENCE.
OR OTHER METHODS THAT ACHIEVE.
INCREASED ACCESS.
I'M INTERESTED IN BROUGHT IN OUR
REACH TO ENSURE ALL CONSUMERS
CAN PARTICIPATE IN DECISIONS
THAT ARE PARAMOUNT TO CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
THE NEXT ISSUE LIKE TO DISCUSSES
DCA SOCIAL MEDIA MANAGEMENT
POLICY.
AND HOW THE DEPARTMENT SUPPORTS
OUR MONITORS THE BUREAU'S SOCIAL
MEDIA PAGES.
DCA DOES HAVE SOCIAL MEDIA
GUIDELINES THAT UP HELLO THAT
CALL GIRLS FOLLOW.
IN OUR BOARDS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
ADOPT THESE GUIDELINES IS NEEDED
TO SERVE THEIR PARTICULAR NEEDS.
OUR GUIDELINES ADDRESS ISSUES
RELATED TO ACCOUNTABILITY.
ACCOUNT MANAGEMENT.
CONTENT IN SUPPORT FOR
ADMINISTRATORS AND PUBLISHERS.
ADDITIONALLY DC HAS GUIDELINES
IN PLACE RELATED TO CONTENT THAT
MAY BE DEEMED INAPPROPRIATE
VULGAR OR INFLAMMATORY.
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT IS HIRED AN
INFORMATION OFFICER. TO DEDICATE
MORE TIME TO THE DEPARTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS SOCIAL MEDIA STRATEGY.
THE INFORMATION OFFICER MONITORS
AND REVIEWS ANALYTICS TO
DETERMINE WHAT TYPE OF POST GET
THE BEST ENGAGEMENT.
AND HELPS THE OTHER INFORMATION
OFFICERS INTENT FOR THEIR
CLIENTS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN DC'S
INFORMATION OFFICERS GROUP
CREATED NEARLY ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
DIRECTLY BENEFITING OUR CLIENTS.
THAT ARE POSTED ON PCA'S SOCIAL
MEDIA SITES.
THE BOARDS IN DERECHOS OWN THEIR
SOCIAL MEDIA PRESENCES AND IN
SOME RARE CASES.
WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S INFORMATION
OFFICERS ARE ALLOWED TO POST ON
THEIR BEHALF.
DISEASE INFORMATION OFFICERS
MONITOR SOCIAL MEDIA PAGES
REGULARLY.
THEY WERE CLOSELY WITH THE BOYS
IN BUREAU SAID ABOUT CONTENT AND
REGULARLY PROVIDE SUGGESTED
POSTS.
DCA WAS RECENTLY MADE AWARE OF
POSTS ON BSI **** FACEBOOK PAGE
THAT ARE DISTASTEFUL AND
CONVEYED THAT THE PAGE MAY NOT
BE MONITORED BY THE BUREAU.
AS SOON AS WE WERE NOTIFIED THE
DCA COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION
CONNECTED WITH THE B. S. I. S.
TO CREATE A PLAN TO ESTABLISH
HIS SOCIAL MEDIA PLAN MOVING
FORWARD.
NEXT I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE
EFFORTS DCA IS DOING TO
IMPLEMENT AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT AUTHORED BY SOME IN WHICH
YOU ENSURE LOW.
AND SUPPORT OUR PROGRAMS TO MEET
THE JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY HAVE
A NATION IMPLEMENTATION DATE.
VERY SOON AFTER AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY IT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
DO YOU SEE A WENT TO WORK
ASSISTING OUR PORTS AND BUREAUS
WITH IMPLEMENTATION.
DCA DRAFTED IN IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE AND THE TIME WHEN WAS
THEN SHARED WITH OUR BOARD
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS AND BUREAU
CHIEFS IN OCTOBER.
THIS TIME I'M WORKS BACKWARDS
FROM JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY AND
PROVIDE SEVERAL BENCHMARKS TO
ENSURE PROGRAMS REMAIN ON TRACK.
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION.
THE CITY IS LEGAL AND
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIVISIONS
HAVE CONVENE VARIOUS MEETINGS
WITH BOARD EXECUTIVE OFFICERS
AMPERE CHIEFS. TO IDENTIFY MAJOR
CHALLENGES AND ASSIST IN
IMPLEMENTATION.
DO YOU SEE A HAS PROVIDED
GUIDANCE ON POTENTIAL REGULATORY
PASS AND MODEL LANGUAGE TO
ASSIST IN DEVELOPING REGULATIONS.
THAT CONFORM TO THE CHANGES IN
pOUR LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION HAS
KHôNG HAS CONSULTED WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATION ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW. TO RECEIVE FEEDBACK
FEEDBACK ON THE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT AND MODEL LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE ALL RELEVANT PARTIES ARE
INFORMED ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S
APPROACH TO PROMULGATING.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT
REGULATIONS.
WE ENCOURAGE PORTS TO CALENDAR
BOARD MEETINGS AROUND THE
PROPOSED AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
TIMELINE. TO ENSURE BOARDS ARE
NOT TO LATE.
BASED ON BOARD MEETING SCHEDULES.
THE DEPARTMENT IS TRACKING THE
IMPLEMENTATION BY ITS BOARD AND
GROW SO WE STAY ON TARGET.
DO YOU SEE A ESTIMATED A. B. C.
P. TO CREATE A DEDICATED.
REGULATIONS UNIT THAT WOULD BE
SOLELY FOCUSED ON REGULATIONS.
AND PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT BERMAN
TATIAN.
DC ANTICIPATES WORKING ON A AT
LEAST FORTY REGULATORY PACKAGES
AS A RESULT OF AB.
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT EVERY BOARD
IMPAIR WAS WORKING TOWARDS
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS IN TIME
TO BE IMPLEMENTED BY JULY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FINALLY I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS
INCLUDING BREEZE AND
HIGHLIGHTING OUR WORK ON
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION. TWENTY
OF DC'S BOARDS AND BUREAUS ARE A
BREEZE. 92% OF ONLINE OR NEW
APPLICATIONS FOR THE BOARDS IN
BUREAUS ARE PROCESS THE SAME DAY.
WITHOUT STAFF IN YOUR BED
WITHOUT STAFF INTERVENTION.
THAT IS A HUGE WIN. SEVENTEEN
BOARDS IN BUREAUS ARE NOT
EMBRACE.
MORE THAN TWO YEARS AGO DCA MADE
THE DECISION NOT TO FORCE THESE
PROGRAMS ON TO REDUCE.
INSTEAD EACH PROGRAM IS GOING
THROUGH CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
TECHNOLOGIES PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE.
EACH PROGRAM IS DEVELOPING
INDIVIDUAL PLANS TO MODERNIZE
THEIR BUSINESS LANDSCAPE WITH A
CAR WITH A COMBINATION OF
PROCESS RE ENGINEERING.
AND TECHNICAL LOGICAL VAST
ADVANCEMENTS.
THE INDIVIDUAL PLANS WERE
DELIVERED TO A LEGISLATURE IN
DECEMBER.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN STATUS UPDATES
FOR PROVIDED IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR PROGRAMS
HAVE COMPLETED STAGE.
TWO AND TWO PROGRAMS HAVE
COMPLETED STAGE ONE THESE
PROGRAMS ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORT THE CURRENT BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLANS.
I'M CONFIDENT WE ARE NOW ON THE
RIGHT TRACK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT TO THE FEE TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE JOINT
COMMITTEES TO DISCUSS THESE
IMPORTANT MATTERS.
I'M HAPPY TO I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DIRECTOR
FEEL ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CAN BE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
AT C. NO QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS.
ITEM SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM A TRICK OF THE FEEL I JUST
WANT.
TO OFFER SO --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COLLABORATION --
PERSONALLY BUT ALSO YOUR STAFF
AND WORKING BOTH WITH SENATE BMP
AND ALSO THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE --
THERE ARE NUMBER OF OUTSTANDING
ISSUES I KNOW THAT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO ADDRESS
AND YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN VERY
TRANSPARENT.
IN DOING SO --
THIS IS ABOUT A CONSUMER
PROTECTION FOR EXCELLENCE ON AND
WE WANT TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE AND A YOU'VE HELPED TO
FACILITATE THAT SO THE PURPOSE
OF THIS INFORMATIONAL.
A HEARING IS TO DO JUST THAT TO
IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES OF IMPROVEMENT AND
CAN CHEWING --
TO WORK WITH CONTINUE
STAKEHOLDERS IN IN A COMFORTING
THAT LIKELY AS WELL TOO SO I
HAVING SAID THAT ANY FINAL
CONCLUDING REMARKS --
ECHO IT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
MATTER LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE
TO DO SO AND FOR PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I'D BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T THANK.
THE MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT THAT ARE THERE IN THE
TRENCHES DAY IN DAY OUT --
ABSOLUTELY CO PROTECTING
CONSUMERS --
IN PREPARATION FOR THE SUNSET
HEARING I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
I ALSO --
THINKING GIVE PRAISE --
TO MY ASSISTANT DEPUTY FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS A DENNIS
CUEVAS ROMERO AND HIS TEAM AND
THEN -- THE
SENIOR STAFF --
THAT ASSISTED IN THESE EFFORTS
AS WELL I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THAT WILL CONCLUDE THE